and we are finally love who would have
thought oh my oh my lord the last word
would eat artists and Lord kognito
returns after one week hiatus
how are you doing sir I'm doing good by
the way
shut up the world watching this what's
up what's up Otis we got eyeballs now we
are humans and ninja and cheetah are
actually humans good yeah you were
impact so I'll let you talk about that
for a minute just kind of get that
firsthand on thoughts me I've been
playing psyche role which I'll give into
after you get to that just when you
start talking about a ninja game a ninja
game yeah I gotta gotta make sure you
get in there okay yeah absolutely but
yeah it's just been kind of an
interesting time for a lot of things
going on so we have some very
interesting topics today if you guys saw
the thumbnail and yeah I'm trying not to
spoil too much just because these are
gonna be topics in themselves via house
backs man like you got to make that trip
dude man packs was really good well I've
been going on with me but on packs
actually came with a good time nice
distraction and um just got out hit the
ground running man got to see a lot of
new titles that's coming up days going
especially for bone so nice I'd got
touched at UM Streets of Rage for the
classic feel you done saying messing
around with that so yeah there was a lot
of good games a lot I really like
passage because um a lot of times you'll
see a lot of new studios or studios
you've never heard before this take
their debut game and you get to a chance
to kind of showcase you know see what
they're about before these guys like
become stars or whatever so that was
cool and I'm from the looters shooter
standpoint obviously the Borderlands
reveal solves the other that's slightly
large we will talk about that I'll be at
the technical issues but you know but uh
lately watching that when I was going
down yeah shout out the Randy Pitchford
Batman I'm gonna tell you right now any
normal human being would have melted
down during that segment of like a debut
and whatever reason it just went left
packs couldn't handle it and I gotta
give him credit I think it's his like I
heard he's a magician for real like
he does like magic tricks and stuff so
um yeah man like his his showmanship
came through made everybody laugh got
through and then finally you have to
take three they got the video going so
that was cool
hey not the anthem devs were there too
no Bungie no division stuff but the
anthem knows what they're doing signings
I don't don't know why they're doing
autograph signing that story hey you
know get it down it's like getting that
rookie left Rickey's trading card get
that poster sign then like you know when
patch 1.8 2.0 comes out I've never been
to one of those events though at some
point I've got to make it maybe South
just because it's close to me absolutely
I mean you know awesome you know what I
hours down here so absolutely as a game
where you owe it to yourself man you
gotta check it out man for sure
something good about me just kind of
general work stuff but I have been
enjoying it up oh so I don't know if you
guys have if you haven't heard of SEK
euro shadows night twice it is another
from software game so if at some point
you've heard a blood-borne which is only
on PlayStation which was so good any of
the Dark Souls titles Demon Souls was
the first one before all of that this is
the new one by the same people now it is
a from software game but it is a
different animal completely on its own
like it has some very distinct
differences to it but also just as
punishing which is something you're like
oh you can res hopefully that's fine
yes but no like seriously you have so it
says shadows that's why so you have a
chance to resurrect yourself in the
middle of a fight which is actually
something you can use strategically
mm-hmm which changes the fight up but if
you like if you die both times you can't
get your stuff back Wow so normally like
if I'd go on blood-borne I'd be working
through like a tough area of get like
you know ten thousand quote experience
points they all have different names if
I die but I make it back to my body I
can make all that stuff up good to go
okay school so that's like how those
generally working this one if you die on
the spot you can res but if you don't
make it out of that encounter and die
again just because you probably were
fighting somebody
from the first place it's all gone Dave
so mechanic yeah so it's a switch on
everything that kind of flipped on its
head normally a lot of Dark Souls and
blood-borne was I mean I played
blood-borne in Dark Souls 3 not as much
the older ones but both of those are
learning mechanics of an encounter which
you still have to do but it's like
getting in getting some damage and
getting out like some giant crazy
Lovecraftian boss is gonna do that like
this big slow slam and if you're not out
of the way you're screwed on this one
I'm like another like you know like
Shanghai ninja night guy and like you
gotta be in the mix like it's completely
the exact opposite you want to like
parry parry swipe once like parry parry
swipe dodge swipe like it's so much
almost more active combat because I
finally got to probably the first fight
that forced me to learn it it's one of
these that took me like three hours
mm-hmm
was the Jinna cheerio fight and it's for
the first probably major fight that I
had to truly be aggressive and parry
like slowly like whittle away a Knick
but really it's all about their posture
you each have posture and it's kind of
you're basically you consider that the
stability of your stance and the more
like more heavy blocks like more
damaging shots that you can block like a
lot but the more you block the more your
posture is like getting staggered and
staggered and if you're positive breaks
your stagger and they can get something
rough on you
but what you gotta do is flip the script
on them break their posture and then you
get a deathblow now if you do that to a
normal enemy that's just a kill but boss
enemies have two or three death blows
that are required and Wow so you break
them stab them and do this and this guy
he had to health bubble so I was like
cool so first one all right sweet we
going good we come on good all right
sweet we're getting him low
we're getting him low get the deathblow
cinematic starts and then we're back
we're back on Phase three and now he's
got lightning I was like today changing
up the beat so nice yeah it's it's
definitely still a fromsoft game but
it's also it's got like there's lore
wise reasons but it's got a training guy
that you can it's a guy that you can
fight and like kind of practice
abilities encounters and stuff and you
can kill them over and over and over
kind of undying or something like that
but mm-hmm it's really cool you have a
grappling hook which is awesome nice
yeah it was about 10:00 to vibe I loved
seeing that a spike in the stealth
aspect yeah so it gives you a different
type of traversal around and there's a
lot of stealth to it as well because if
you have a lot of enemies in one area
you're not really advised to take on
like six enemies it's just not how this
works you want to like grapple grapple
between two trees take out this first
guy then take out the gunner up on a
perch and then go through this grass and
take this guy out and then kind of work
and Whittle your way around and then
finally when you've cleared everything
then you can go fight the boss die and
then try and do it all over again like a
photo I got though so I didn't count the
deaths on jtro but I was on my stream
for there's a guy he's a mini-boss mini
boss mind you 64 deaths
Wow I know you're not giving me a lot of
confidence right now you know give me a
lot of confidence right now so what I
can but I can also tell you the moment
like those recording moments when I
actually beat some of these bosses are
some of the highs of gaming's - look I'm
gonna be way down here on the lows
getting just mounted into the ground as
soon as I noon it through the roof oh
that's a good point though it's the
satisfaction real quick I know we talked
a lot of Sacro um I did some controversy
in these gaming streets and reference to
easy modes and I wanted to know your uh
your stance on that sir so these games
when you get to the point that you can
speedrun them which is kind of how I
feel a easy mode would go they can be
done quick they can be done in like an
hour
so the part of this game is truly
learning the mechanics learning the
fights having the exploration some of
the tension of like do I go around this
corner I don't just sprint through
everything so yeah easy mode in a game
like take god of war for example that's
a perfect one that I think easy modes
there because you're experiencing the
story seeing the world seeing all the
different you know elements of boss
fights and things that happened there's
a lot to it
if you easy mode Dark Souls or suck hero
for example mm-hmm it's like an old Mega
Man game like I played the and they have
the save States now so you can literally
like this is a tough spot I'm gonna save
right here and load it over
over and over and that makes it so much
easier to get through as opposed to fact
I slice and start it over all the way
that's how it used to be it was like
yeah okay eat bit Nintendo Mega Man
three oak beam but that also made me you
know kind of a gamer let in like a
nation gamer to be like I'm gonna learn
this I'm gonna practice it I'm gonna I
hate the term get good because it just
sounds so cheesy
it's so crummy but elitist I'm looking
for it sounds elitist and that's not it
but it is it is a game that breaks you
to some learned skill sixty more deaths
is not something a lot of people are
probably gonna want to do but when we
figured this guy out and then in
Jannetty are the same thing even more
it's like I've got he's going it's like
he does like two swings he'll like shoot
his bow like I could memorize the fights
like I learned this boss I know this
boss like the back of my hand and that's
mhm and that's the point where you get
to and it's really really cool so that's
why it I would say it depends on the
game like if you want to explore through
it and you just want like hey I want to
wander around and I know I can swipe
these guys and if you get killed then
you know it's like you can rise up and
you could say an easy mode would be
infinite resevoir something so you get
the feel of the death maybe but nah I
mean it's interesting because I saw that
debate while I was away and um I was
just like wow this is you know I'm
saying like I seen it was it was both
canceiied like very strong arguments you
know and you know your side as well as
the other side say hey you know I have
issues and you know what's the point no
I mean it's not gonna affect anybody if
it's there and I'm kind of with you I'm
like you know at the end of the day like
here's the thing I think people are
confusing like difficulty like with
accessibility and people with
disabilities right now people with
disabilities and stuff like that yeah
this should be an option you know like I
said Xbox has an adaptive controller
whatever that's you know no doubt go for
it but as far as difficulty I do
struggle with the easy mode in the sense
that where my thing is I don't like to
affect a developer's vision right yeah
from software their whole MO has been
let's make these difficult challenging
style games where you have to learn the
mechanics and get through it now saying
it'll be defeated automatically just cuz
an easy mode is in the end but I feel
like
kind of like the discussion we had about
raids and stuff right where it's like
you know not everyone is meant to do it
you know say it's a skill level it's a
certain level of thing it's not to brag
in anyone's face but it's just like for
example what professional sports like
yeah I would love to be an NFL player on
an NBA player right but I have to have
the skill required and put in the work
required to meet said goal and I'm
saying and I think that you know not
everyone is kind of for that and it's
okay there's certain games I know
there's no way I would be able to do XYZ
or complete a certain game it's just not
my mo and I'm okay with that but I think
like people have to be careful I want to
call it I don't be filed as a
participation trophy but you know at the
end of the day every game is not for
everyone and I just struggle with
changing an artist's vision and saying
hey now you have to change this if isn't
if his whole intent was like yo I want
to make games that are hard I want to
make games that are difficult you don't
say that's his whole mo and his whole
mission statement
let it be man so that's where I met so I
was just curious I'm glad you actually
met you talked about it cuz um it was
something idea what I mean it's one of
those even my brother and I have been
talking we talked last week while you
were out so had a nice little chat with
him ended up being like 2 hours long so
I was crazy
sad stone whoa still yup stone wolf but
it's like you get into a similar thing
too and this is kind of where I don't
have a proper answer for this because
you think about like tier 3 reckoning
mm-hmm so you have matchmaking as an
option if you get a crap group of people
who don't have like supers that
synergize together you don't have a
tether which is almost required
well of Radiance or bubble or both like
if somebody if you know three people
walking be like oh let me try tier three
because I did tier two but Laura even
tier 1 to tier 2 the bridge is hard is
hard all of that stuff you come in there
it's like randoms aren't gonna be able
to do it but all my brother literally
wants is like I just want the shirt he
just wants the jersey and he but it's
also you've got like you've got so many
RNG factors you've got the modifiers
that will it make some day tough to do
or nearly impossible depending if it's
gonna be like brawler and attrition it's
like I'm not gonna
play that day yeah exactly exactly and
that's like that but I was like that's
almost that's to a point where it's like
the MA orangey modifiers are so poorly
like poorly paired together or they're
just to a point of like being ridiculous
because the encounter is hard enough you
have snipers on both sides and then epic
rap going on you got the Slams which is
really getting old my brother keeps
pointing it out but yeah everything
slams and you're on oh let me walk on
this tiny little thing I just need to -
for the first time yes actually love it
but we'll talk about that I mean yeah
it's yeah we'll get to that but it's
just kind of the whole difficulty thing
and it's like and then he's got his kids
for example that like barely might be
jumping into like 600 then as they
slowly work up should they ever even try
the reckoning I don't I mean probably
not doing that yeah so it's like I don't
I don't have an answer for all of it I
don't know I like easy mode for me those
specific to psyche row I think it would
get like a Mega Man vibe or they would
need some delivery if you turn this on
you this game may feel basically short
it's kind of what I would say is because
you must go through smash Abbas smash
Abbas Abbas and it's not like the risk
reward of going through and setting up
the fight and learning you think each
thing now not everybody's gonna spend
three hours or 64 deaths on a boss most
you guys are probably quicker than I
would but that being said it's like
that's part of my experience but now
when I do that and I go play are there
things they're gonna be faster cuz I can
get that that's like there's some point
in these games were it breaks you mm and
if you stick a stick with it you've now
started to understand how the game works
absolutely yeah it's like waiting people
out with English 101 like you're gonna
stay in college you're gonna stick with
this game it's like if you actually
stick with this this is the time you
have to figure out how this whole
process works and sadly for people who
play Dark Souls and blood-borne you have
to figure this process out over again at
one of these fights you can kind of like
force your way through some of this
stuff but up to a point no you got to
relearn it and it's just one of those
things it is part of their vision and I
think for SEC euro an easy mode
to me doesn't quite make sense for other
things for accessibility I totally
understand those pieces you know those
are really really cool but it's like if
you I think in this specific case it
would feel like Megaman will save states
you'd burn yeah I think that's a great
example I think you just nailed it
because those games like we grew up and
over those days you know the three lives
you know that's it maybe one continue
listen man I mean I'm with you bro I
think I think that is the deal shout out
the game of what a look at those pretty
much four days killed us but I'm addy
bothers you won't let me show my ninja
shirt man I want to show it off he pulls
his hand up I'm not standing
it's literally I can see like here row
the [ __ ] exact the ninjas in all his
glory and it can't be ca to the face and
what is for the fancy buns no one want
you to see it I got a guilt on y'all I
got a guilty with the power the how are
those tracks going over my back over
listen I gotta make my debut kind of hot
out here man you gotta make it right
video itself would say what's everybody
to chant they finally got this thing
going man so yeah well thank you guys
but yeah I mean honestly sucker has been
awesome so far I like the vibe to it I
like the differences in the mechanics
the in it this is one thing about the
game the final piece I'll say on it in a
Dark Souls game you have RPG elements
like health and strength and like attack
kind of at it they all have their own
like strengths so as you if you want to
grind out killing the same enemies over
and over and over that you do feel
comfortable with you eventually could
get to a point where you have more
health you can hit harder and some of
the future enemies would get easier for
a boss you can take bigger chunks a
damage this doesn't work that way mmm -
well there are certain checkpoints when
you get to bosses the way you get health
on the way you get like a little bit
more attack power is killing the bosses
it's not the low level ads you have to
fight the big guys to get some steps up
flow and you can't just yeah you can't
just grind stuff out so yeah it it has
the respawn mechanic and it has like the
grappling for some more stealth but on
the other side it's just as punishing
because you can't grind out and just
over level something so nuts it's a hell
of a lot of fun but it's also
kicking my butt a lot so I'm enjoy
minute so nice nice refreshing change it
seems yeah and that's it
sometimes that's what we need and what
kind of get into the some reasons for a
change and a break and you know breath
and fresh air so yes sir whoa
so Bungie still keeps making this
destiny to game yeah so you said you got
to play tier two reckoning for the first
time how was that aired today was done
this week was the first time I would
play games about two weeks and um I was
like you know what I have to touch
destiny it's been so long so I touched
it and um yeah I literally did tit - for
the first time didn't know what to
expect
started off killing ads and then it's
like yeah make a make a right and go up
a bridge and I'm like okay so go on
there then it's like hold down a circle
okay boom
hurry up go to the next circle and it
was getting intense like I was getting
into it I was it felt like a it felt
like a mini section of raid like I was
really digging it it was like super
intense like I know I was feeling it
because I had my slover lot line up you
know my whole gear set to get Nova bombs
and like really powerful weapons and I
was like we were barely holding on and
it went like a couple of Randall's there
was one other world like he had the
welder radio it's kind of holding the
spot down that's probably the reason you
made it through yeah man like literally
I I didn't see that I realized the
importance of it and um it was just
intense action-packed you got ads from
the front boss from the back gotta watch
your side watch the flanks then his
sniper is going on I'm like okay cool
and you have to be fast and efficient
which is what I like so then when I got
we died a couple times then that like
the second time we got it so I'm
thinking we get to the bridge is over
I'm like yeah and so we did whoo
there's like not jump the reporter oh my
god Jeff oh no so gentle portal then it
felt like two dark blades from d1
there's some weight like the whole motif
is dope like it's real dogged you get in
there you trying to find out where this
guy's at and um yeah man like I was
digging it was hard I still haven't
completed it but I love the intensity I
love the whole motif I was actually into
the 9 as far as the whole heart talking
and talking about the dredge in and all
that stuff and um yeah Forte said it's
cool wait till you see out evil
no we're Tier three is like two three oh
man that sounds crazy so I would I would
have to say I'm feeling it
digging it you know I'm saying this it's
a mini little raid I can't wait to do
more and I honestly didn't think I would
enjoy it as much as I did so that's
that's my thing right now on tier two
reckoning nice mm-hmm yeah Tier three
will kick your butt - mm-hmm what'd they
give me this boiler well what's going so
two options the bridge one of them you
go down a flight tonight's but they're
harder oh wow another one you fight eh
what the hell is it called like a
reflection of Oryx hmm
so it's kind of like the regicide
mission looking one mmm okay so that and
he's just got some mechanics where he'll
either do enough damage if you don't do
enough damage he'll basically wipe two
of you then you got a resin up and it's
not the biggest platform you'll have a
couple like two big takin overs that
spawned like in pairs with him depending
on where he's at
that's basically more a damage check
than anything it feels like in kind of
some coordination well of Radiance
bubble stuff like that seems to be just
required so when my brother knighted
tier 3 did it last week so trying to
think how we did it I ran which way
Sentinel shield the new big one that you
shoot through one my brother knows what
running bubble okay and then we had at
least one tether with us and I'm regular
here I was doing but those three at
least made it work because I can hold
mine up for and honestly half the time
it depends on the rolls and this is
where some of the orangey it's like
going through something like secure
where I memorize encounters and don't
know what's coming the RNG of like hey
what's gonna be the the bridge spawn
well okay if I get you know a what am I
thinking of a Minotaur if I have one of
those come at me on the bridge I'm like
okay it's like we can deal with it get
the bubble it's workable if there's a
giant failing that spawns and the shield
blasts already gives some range off I
was like and that's just one of those
they love either blasting you off or
smashing you off and it's like I'm kind
of getting tired of those mechanics
because that's it's a lot of the game
every
it's like yeah who's to melees and we'll
talk about that here in a minute for
what that's a metaphor like I don't want
to get close in melee anything I really
don't like the only thing I'm gonna
melee is like a Thrall you know I hate
you and I know what you say as far as
some repetition with the mechanics in
terms of bosses I hate you that I will
say though um I do like the intensity of
the fight because it's imperative to
keep everyone alive because of the
timing of this so quick it's Cory and
like you the team could really go south
to minute to people hotel because the
other two are now worrying about
residence then the damage is coming in
and then it snowballs and it's like whoa
you know and I actually like that you
know say it was it's a different feel
again I got to finish it through but I
got it like I really like I mean I know
shadow throne is your jam that's cue the
soloist and you do your lap you know you
think this is me like this one I was
like I like it you'll tell me when you
jump in is down the whole damn music
know it gets you public you ready to
rocket it's the first time I embrace the
night I was like oh I'm feeling this
she's talking you know she's telling me
stuff and then they dissatisfied if you
don't do it like I like this so shout
out to the record and it's my first time
I'm new maybe to get old you know for me
at some time like as you guys are much
for me I'm definitely yeah shout to
dramatic
she said well with Phoenix protocol here
one of it one of my random yeah yeah and
I was the way I did pop well every every
point all six of them yeah huge if he
gets Heather pairing up with well of
Radiance and Phoenix protocol and
Orpheus really it's like oh you got very
specific builds that make it work and
this is one of those points where are
Angie well not even orangy matchmaking
with randoms oh it's a crapshoot as
who's gonna bring but somebody's like
hey I'm gonna bring my Golden Gun in
you're like no no no and it but it's
like a lot of people won't even read
text yet even if I type it feels like
even if I take the time to type it out
there huh
I don't know it would pay to taste you
know mm-hmm the flow yeah it's kind of
one of those that's stuff like this
continues to prove why trades and
matchmaking like unless they truly did
like an easy mode raid for the
experience not the gear but you can get
like hey you can see this thing you'll
get some your rent you know stuff that's
like 20 levels below or something like
that
yeah you can go see it cool you're gonna
get much from it but you don't get much
from it yeah but no randoms randoms in
there I thought about it even last night
cuz there were a couple of people I saw
I was like oh let's see if we get it and
even just the team group that we had
just wasn't working last night between
what was happening and just were like we
give up and he's like they want to look
for a match make him like I'm out I'd be
like nope I'm good nope I'm done so how
much of the in speaking of the nine how
many of the invitations the nine have
you cottony been out for oh I'm so
behind I just did the first um I'm like
halfway I think I'm up to this the last
part of the second I believe it's like
savathun song special mission or
something
um but yeah I've been I've been out of
commission man I'm just now kind of
getting back in the game and again
slowly but um yeah I have to get that
done because I really I love the first
one and the first one was really cool
like I really like learning about Trajan
in this non-relationship and I love that
she's just talking crap about him and I
got to find out what's going on no one's
answer me I know you nobody do not spoil
because I'm very very very very curious
where this is going
but I will just say is it good are you
satisfied lore wise what you're learning
with these things so I'm only three and
I'm looking like all of them some people
are doing them on all three characters
and get an extra lore from it I don't
think they can see the cinematics but
they're getting some of the lore stuff
that they can read there's stuff in here
I mean I am curious to see where it goes
and we're gonna talk about spoilers we
will be talking about some leaks and
things just you know some rumors if
nothing else man yeah stuff that seems
like good be true
but it does seem to be headed in that
direction so it just seems to be
corroborating what you keep hearing it
all seems to be like meshing together so
so far
the first cinematic was really cool
having anything quite to that level yet
they said it won't be the only one I
don't know if it's gonna be the first in
like the last maybe or there's one or
two in the middle it's been three weeks
so this'll before so maybe you will see
what the cadence is you know they're
gonna space them out but they have been
a little interesting some have been very
short and you're just kind of like okay
now I have more questions than answers
so it's one of those moments to where
help help tell me more tell me more nope
okay right okay so it's kind of those
moments at points but so far at least
it's in it and it's not overly long I do
hope they get a little variety because
so far it's been go to this plane it
killed these races do a straight yeah
plane Achilles races do a strike go to
neces can all three of these races do a
strike mmm and then you just go see what
happens I'm like can you not mix it up a
little more yeah a little bit and you'll
pass structure what I mean that's one of
those things even when it comes to the
boundary design I don't know how hard
like the bounty
you know registration and things within
their engine are what I feel like I
could sit there and make like 100 more
bounties or at least like 50 more like
there's you know just to have some more
variety as opposed to seeing the same I
mean it was really really blatant when
it came to Hawthorne for example those
are really like the daily bounties
before they took them away we're very
very specific so yes so it got kind of
good so same thing here I'm hoping we
get a little variety or if I mean
they're supposed to I don't know how
many weeks of it it's they're gonna be
but after a point they're gonna run out
of plane it's hmm so we'll see but the
lore pieces are pretty cool I am
enjoying those no doubt no doubt
so Bungie felt like a swab I know you
were out last week we talked about some
stuff and trying to think there's
anything major that dropped last week
let me give it I mean I know iron banner
came they had the nightfall rotation so
gonna be getting better and there's some
so a couple things for the patch that
will be coming I just want to briefly
touch on it with you and just kind of
get your thoughts more kind of the time
for some of the stuff to get implemented
so give me your quick give you a quick
like 1 2 shot answers nightfalls are
going to have a better road
patient like cycle so you don't have
like stuck on the same one good thing
yeah cool they're worse should it obtain
this long mm-hmm I feel like some of
this stuff wouldn't season the drifter
came it came out like broke their rolls
but this one actually makes sense though
8:01 weapon frames gonna have all six
starting next week just oh yeah yeah
yeah thank you blast furnace thank you
you know other things besides bow and
hand cannon and auto rifle yeah and then
just dreaming drop rates for most of the
cosmetics are getting buff like thousand
thousand voices gonna get a buff there's
different lore books invitations of the
nine like having the handicap multiplier
be able to go up by twenty five instead
of one like stuff just quality life
stuff to change it and it's kind of like
thank you but some of that stuff like
the dreaming City cosmetics the last
wish cosmetics I mean they literally
bumped the date out for the cosmetics
and stuff like that I'm like you can't
go in there and change like a random
number drop on some of the stuff yeah
we're like it's already random enough in
itself that it's frustrating and there's
no like check that hey if I do 20 raids
I'm gonna get thousand voices at some
point like you got to put like a finish
line of somebody doing enough raids to
be like hey at least if you run 20 I
know if I ride do you think I guess
we've been through that before but do
you ever think watching people go like
you know go through one rain and get it
and somebody go through a hundred raids
and not get thousand voices like how how
much is enough for some people I think
they just need to apply what they've
already applied what they did for
escalation protocol which is put in some
type of algorithm that with each
completion the percentage and your
probabilities go up so they just gotta
apply it with this I listen I understand
it's a rare rare you know raid item in
vain of like effects with the class kind
of a deal but um you know I mean I do
agree does suck for people who have run
it that many times and it's like they're
not getting it so yeah just use the
whole escalation protocol theory you
know algorithm get that off dust that
off put that in the end because they
have to have the numbers on who actually
has a thousand voices be that you know
that crazy
so that's a shout at the Forte he's got
36 clears know thousand voices that's
rough
- 36 Wow
damn yeah it's again I've heard numbers
higher in either way it's just like mmm
come on now yeah it's a bit brutal well
that's that I mean brief touch on last
week there's nothing too crazy in there
so this week we finally got to get a
kind of idea I think of our cake yes awk
week van I got talked about this it is a
storm is brewing perhaps next week we'll
kick off what we what we've been calling
Ark week our goal for this happening has
been to take the element that makes the
sandbox crackle and put it on the
microscope the most noticeable update is
that we improve mini ark subclass pass
for the time before Forsaken which I
want to stop right there mm-hmm
yeah we I'm not bringing that up I'm
bringing up the fact that how long did
it take for it to change okay okay yeah
we talked about that before I won that
bet that's fine that's what this really
was no it's the fact like I know like
there are subclass tier trees that have
not been touched and how like you wait
for Ark week in April this crap came out
in September it's always a little seven
months so we had a subclass balancing
like so
I mean is there I just don't even think
I don't think that's acceptable anymore
the way especially many games have been
updating faster and patching quicker and
in a sub classes take bouncing but
there's a point where there's two
questions and this will get in the
bantam talk a little bit later yes one
is like the engine of like how slow and
what does it take for them to empower
with the changes about something to get
to and - or is it or in it I think that
is compounded by their whole must be
data must have tested and they do tend
to release things that are somewhat okay
but then though released like hey here's
this new thing we tested the crap out of
it we want to make sure and wait and
this stuff's broken it's like it nobody
catches everything so if you don't catch
everything why
wait to them 1 yeah I mean I'm of the
mindset that it's gotta be the tools
because um you know it just doesn't make
any sense you know obviously we went
from part 1 d1 to d2
they already expressed that how you know
it was supposed to be more of an
improved you know engine and them to be
a little bit more agile what fixes but
the reality is they have shown it's
better than d1 but it's still not to the
point where they can kind of jump in and
make quicker cadence changes especially
balanced batches and what-have-you so
you know I know they're their big data
drive driven you know they they always
go through all the data and they look at
all that kind of stuff and we get that
but even certain changes recently like a
couple 12 go they're like yeah that's
coming you know where would you let you
know about it but that's gonna come down
the line we're still fixing things you
know so to me that's again just looking
for the outside in I have no evidence it
screams to me that the engine is still
not as fast and as intuitive as they
would like because we're gonna get into
almost what but we'll get into spectral
blades right and we're gonna that's
another to me that's another yeah that's
another example right there so again
we'll see what happens but um yeah they
gotta get a little bit more quicker man
and I'll get a new engine for d3 if
that's the case absolutely now they say
this week fool also feature arc singe
and arc bounties to synergize with
updated abilities to provide approving
yawns for all this to be energy mayhem
will be available in crucible arc week
will also feature this is the one you
guys want open your ears for one of the
most powerful arc weapons ever created
thunderlord will be back from April 9th
April 23rd if you don't have it please
if you're out of town for those weeks
telephone to get it somehow make sure
you get this gun you got it early and
lucky on PC very lucky man that was my
baby on Xbox and to get it in a Rando
drop they had the Lords of orange Jesus
state knows less that was like saving
grace for you in the beginning I don't
know I just got thunder Lord I'm like
well you're satu you're totally fine you
can do things yes that allowed me to do
things you know saying definitely and
obviously you hook me
with the whisper but um yeah without my
sleep or without other things I really
felt weak out there to be able to solo
content and yet done little even even
with the nerf to machine guns recently
its new oh it's still strong yeah bosses
definitely feel a little slower to kill
them yeah I agree I agree the single
target dps is a little longer yep
so do you think just by reading that
will kind of get into the subclass
changes mmm we didn't know what this was
and they say arcs engine arc bounties I
mean arc bounties being arc related
that's fine arc singe do you think it's
a little just gonna be like hey these
strikes the story missions the
adventurers these have arc singe and
then reckoning will have arc singe do
you think they'll have it anywhere else
that would typically have a singe mmm
good question um I don't know I don't
know why I get the vibe it might be
conservative and one that on that part
you know it may be limited to just a
couple of activities it would be
interest to see if they spread it across
all activities Argus says no but hey you
know I will say this as we get into more
of these notes as regards to our Queen I
personally pleasantly surprised with
other things and we're gonna get into
that absolutely I don't know it's just
kind of late will you a new arc weak but
it's like we're solar and void week
there's no mention of those there's no
thought there's no
including yeah it just debuted the blue
given time no but it's like you gotta do
one you gotta feel like okay you can of
course or none of course of course I
think this is a series man and the cops
should be educated oh so it's like I
think I think this is definitely a
series a day of playing around with and
yeah honestly to me there's no doubt
like you and you would have to do void
you'd have to do solar league right at
this point so one would think mmhmm yep
yeah so so but class changes after the
release of forsaken the sandbox team
wanted to revisit some older subclass
fascism like no kidding it's April it's
all grouchy today that's something that
I
it's about before and you were like then
it came out and then we're like yeah but
it's like we haven't talked about it so
long I forgot that it's been like
something we didn't talk about back in
oh we talked about it like August and
September saying hey these sound really
cool they sound so cool the other ones
are gonna get out shine they got out
shined and now we're given some changes
it's just like calm it's it is a slow
process and that's why it's like it's
like you know I've played more destiny
too then pretty much anything else in a
long long time but it's like I want to
sit down with some of the different
groups and understand be like so what is
your process to change up a subclass
it's like I would love to just have I
don't want to like bash and be like hey
you guys take too long and stuff let's
like yeah does our frustration and event
but it's like I just want to know it's
like what is the process what what
systems talk to each other what is the
testing process how much goes into the
QA peace what are the the game testers
doing to see what the balance is like
like you have to go test it and gambit
and PvE and PvP and missions and raids
and like there's a lot of places I know
it's not a simple process but I know in
seven months that does at least in my
head sound like a long time so no I hear
you you make a valid point so you're not
you're not off base so I definitely I
definitely hear what you got with that
so yeah we're gonna go ahead and I'll
take the Titan piece do you have this
Boulder you can read it - oh yeah yeah I
mean okay so I'll take the Titan piece
and to share the hunter wish your bunch
of warlocks all yours yeah you already
know keep your hands off that code of
the juggernaut this is your bottom path
this math is all about punching enemies
to get better at shooting them shooting
enemies to create better punching them
we want to further incentivize engaging
in in this loop and make make doing so
more visible and flashy shooting any
mini should make you feel like you're
primed to strike with a melee
okay frontal assault so that's your
melee now increases all weapon damage
for the duration of the buff 25% against
combatants 20% against players duration
from 10 to 16 seconds that's actually
substantial buff timer is now displayed
on the HUD this okay site note one of
those things I talked about my brother
with last week the buff timer being
displayed on the hood
I've really when it comes to whatever
comes in the future especially in d3 I
want more actual Lake intrinsic values
like numbers on swinging more often just
all the time whether it's a number on a
buff whether it's like the range number
on my gun like don't give me a green bar
don't give me an experienced bar that I
can't even hover and see how many - I
need like I want numbered alone ok what
numbers in the game so love timers know
a number and that's just for everything
so if like I mean if I put a super model
what does this do is it ten percent is
it ten seconds just a little more
sounded very division e-tag bility but
like even if I got some of the numbers
on there with the stuff that they have
it still wouldn't even touch division
the division of so much more oh yeah
just now solving some would be good
because they're so more about feel and
I'm like that's fine how it feels but
these to feel pretty close which one's
better
you know so that's one pieces you're
mailing and the knock out melee damage
bonuses increase from 25 to 60 percent
yeah now alters once you have dealt
sixty percent damage to the target any
damage dealt done after sixty percent
will refresh the timer still also
triggers after a shield pop no longer
consumed after one melee attack duration
lasts for three to five so if you do get
that good damage chunk your melees will
hit harder if you do a melee you can go
shoot some things it's got a decent loop
but here's where it kind of brings full
circle back to what I was talking about
how many things am I really gonna melee
in this game unless they're tiny like
the dogs shadow thrall throw yeah I'm
not gonna still find a benefit I'm not
gonna go generally the only time you
risk a melee most of the time on
something tough is hammer strike yes
that's the one where you risk and you
can dash it you better get the hell out
of there quick rate out of there either
way so to be like hey let me shoot some
enemies and let me punch this boss like
I'm not gonna really do that so this one
feels still like okay it's cool but
unless you're just always like send me a
shadow throw then I can shoot the boss
for a little while send me a shadow
throw pop yeah you're right for silly it
doesn't still feel totally viable and it
just feels kind of like a weird tree
to me and just the mail is in general
after being on that tear to bridge
enough every slam it's getting old
every big into me just being like you
can't get near me slam you can't get
near me Sam only enemy that didn't slam
was what was the damn strike with the
shadow guy had the Scorch canand Sevcik
no it's not right what is the name of
Suffolk would just scourge kid on the
traitor you know how talking about the
traitor squirts gain at destiny one do
you want
do you okay you go up the lift and then
you fight him through you know who I'm
talking about though right I know we
talk about wow he was the only one who
would not slam the ground yay he
wouldn't you're right so that's just one
of those pieces I'm like make it a
little just a little bit exodus blue
Alexis black that's on this as a second
d1 so you thought do you want yeah yeah
that guy technically might not smash the
ground either yeah so there's one it's
one in each game one oh yeah so I was
like I mean they're definitely given it
a buff I mean getting your damage buff
to enemies for 16 seconds is solid
having your male a bonus do more is also
solid so I mean you get some bonuses to
this I just don't know how much the
melee I'm really gonna use unless
there's always this this you know little
guy that I get to go bopped in the face
occasionally so fanned out so buff to
the Titan mmm one of them one arc
straighter top and bottom path you know
because they didn't touch the middle
tree and that's the one I don't see a
lot of people play yeah that's also
profit I was gonna say that they didn't
mmm you know so way of the warrior
miss path thrives on striking with
precision and timing and is heavily
melee focused again bags my other issue
to enhance this loop we're giving it a
bit more nuance with higher pay
potential payout we want to allow for
more room to execute and engage with
both the path to success I can't read
apparently benefits combination blow
bonus melee damage can now be stacked
three times mmm
requires a melee ability kill four
each stack mm that's weird I'm thinking
if you use your male ability it's not
instantly back unless there's something
I'm missing right so it's like yeah that
seems a bit wait let's just uh faster we
charge you on melee which I'm not seeing
plus there's something I'm missing
exactly buff increases melee damage by
60% per stack in PvE buff increases
melee damaged about 22% in PvP for
comparison this ability used to stack
one time and melee damage was at 50% so
stats higher kills with this ability now
heal 40 health in addition to starting
health regen so they feel charts good if
you're in the mix but this gets back to
the will just less diversity in classes
mm-hmm so you'd think of a hunter and
you're like okay so if you're gonna be
got the guy up in the mix as a dark
Strider unless I'm in my super I'm not
more anymore in the mix than a Titan in
the world log I'm still gonna be
shooting things from range try not to
get smashed so they they want some of
these classes to be played that way but
the general way to play the game doesn't
feel that way
hmm so Naga Sadow yeah it's interesting
like as we gonna continue to talk about
melee stuff it's got very interesting
the route they're going with certain
things yeah deadly reach increased buff
duration for 6 to 8 seconds buff is no
longer by a melee hit so case drow also
was saying dodge can instantly restore
melee so forget it I sure yep so then we
got arts right away the win if you want
to take that one and roll into the
Warlocks I'll let you have your fun yeah
man oh wait up to win bottom path to
pass about quick movement and thriving
under pressure we want to increase your
ability to survive while at low health
and enhance your elusiveness so you can
be more confident when in danger this
way you just don't get a bus you don't
just get a bonus when you're injured you
have more control of what state you're
in and you can make more risk reward
choices so then we're getting
disorienting blow increases the
disorient this is by 50% mmm increase
duration increase duration of disorient
on players for 1.5 to 2 seconds
focus breathing increased dodge recharge
bonus while sprinting by 100% combat
meditation increased bonus grenade and
melee regeneration when bloodied by 25%
interesting lightning reflexes increase
damage resistance while damaged while
dodging from 25% to 40% in PvP Wow
increased damage resistance while
dodging from 63% to 70% in PvE so
definitely see more of the effect in PvP
no doubt caught on yeah like just a
brief overview way of the wind bottom
path Foxtrot how are you feeling about
that subclass how you feeling about
these changes uh I mean sounds good in
theory for sure I mean some of the stuff
if nothing else I can tell you just the
fact that as you run hmm you hit your
dodge back that much quicker so run
around do this run around do this run
around do this I'm like it's just gonna
make hunters even a little more lethal
in PvP than they already are oh yeah
especially that just watching that cuz
they totally sure they're so lucky that
was rude really really well when you did
the Thorin quest and you have to go find
a class to kill in PvP and you're like
oh which one did I find the hunter was
last you're like oh I blew through that
really quick I couldn't mind I don't
think I could find a warlock to save my
life could not find you guys I'm not out
there on the field we were not out there
to feel like that well you're about I'm
with you man it definitely adds bullet
allottee to them so it's gonna be
interesting so now we got my stall bros
kill all a storm transou top and bottom
path damage scales up to 150 percent
over five seconds of continuous use of
the attack updated FEX and audio to
support this functionality your tickle
fingers about to look better oh boy
I don't I like it well I'll get into I
will talk about
but um or a stormcaller Tumen of
conduction top path notes this path
primarily focus from prep their words
prominently on chain lightning but we
also want to better sell the fantasy of
being a god of erratic and dangerous
energy I want you to be delighted and
surprised by the cast you cause on top
of that we should make the choice of
using your ability something to better
strategize around and reward you for
doing so so Chain Lightning melee can
now chain up to five times up from one
and each individual target can be hit
twice chain damage decrease from 52-31
damage per chain hit interesting arc web
can now change to many more targets and
back and forth between targets the
amount of chaining varies based on youth
and I will leave it to you all to
discover increase chain range from 10
meters to 12 meters chaining arc damage
now reduces the cooldown of your grenade
works with our web chains and chains
with chain lightning melee earn 3%
energy for incidents of chain damage and
PvE earn 10% energy per instance of
change damage in PvP so before we get to
the bottom path and all the other stuff
first off top let me just get into it
um I like that the damage scale up to
150 is needed and I'd only think I have
a little complaint I have to see 5
seconds feels like a long time to me
like in order for that to scale up right
the only way I see that being very
effective is if you're using your DPS in
the boss because we all know storm call
is really not great for boss DPS right
right so I'm tickle finger chicken -
alright boom that's gonna be good for um
you know a boss but I'm like I got to
see how that really is gonna go you know
when you when you're fighting up against
using yellow bars or multiple enemies
because dad you know it does unless
you've got like armed what is it um
crown of Tempest
yeah don't really last that long you
know I'm saying so I got a CI before I
mean it sounds cool I love the damage
scale yeah I just got to see how 5
seconds does five seconds to me feel a
little long but again I haven't touched
it I've played it I have
see it in effect now as far the other
stuff with the chaining and the
lightning melee sounds really cool
you know chain line mail is a very
important melee it's very good from
range so that should be interesting to
see and I like how its bouncing back
again a lot of this I have to see in
effect in you know real-life gameplay
you know say it sounds cool but how
effective is it gonna be that's why you
see but what do you think just about
these two things so far with the storm
rolls I mean yeah kind of be curious
I feel like stormcaller minutes
low-level guys that you're not gonna use
as much for holding it but yeah if you
actually finally sit there and just
focus on a boss like with your tickle
fingers that it's actually probably
gonna hopefully nuwell cross your
fingers
as for the melees and stuff it all
sounds pretty cool and the chaining the
fact that they're just trying to let the
actual chain move around a bit more have
a bit more reach in connections to
things I mean that's the idea it's like
it you know goes all over the place and
hopefully thank you they will so it
sounds pretty cool from what I can tell
I just hope they don't hate some of this
stuff when I face it in PvP you know I
think what you're good at hate is what
I'm about this is the one I'm like okay
stormcaller
a Tumen of the elements bottom path
notes currently this path focused on
creating drone buddies for allies and
staying close to them to dish out more
rifts and the buddies they're in
generally arc drone is short-lived and
you need to stay close to your ref to
keep it around now you'll be able to
take your pal further and if you stick
with friends you'll be able to have it
around much more often making this path
more potent as support electrostatic
surge increase bonus regeneration of
rift by 600% 600% i think it's the the
biggest increase i've ever seen it Wow
per nearby friendly guarded 600% this
sounds insane it's a big boost you would
definitely feel but it was previously
very low extends roof duration from 15
to 20 seconds added a UI notification
when the buff is active arc soul
extended duration by 50% now let's stop
let's stop like those are big ass dumb
excuse language those big-ass numbers
now here's there's two sides of that it
is a really really big buff but also the
fact that if they needed that big of a
buff doesn't that know how far off it
should how far off it was from being
viable ma'am
like if it's if they needed that much
help on it in the first place if you're
talking 50% on the duration of our soul
600 percent per nearby Guardian for
whatever this thing is I don't even
actually know off the top my had to
forget what this is mmm which means we
you know as far as my class research I
don't remember
oh oh that's um when you stay close to
each other and um you do the the whole
think pink member arm was it the
medallions and rise of I'll make thanks
Cory in a way but that goes straight to
your riff to study your super so it's
promoting okay staying close right yeah
let me all right let me give my storm
bro some some some game right now
alright some girls hits deal now
remember that this is just natural buff
with bottom path right just stand close
you get a 600% R if you can get riffs
all day extended look at those rating
knows reading it's an all riff charges
faster analysis right okay now remember
they just bought Vesper of whatever that
thing is the the the yellow and blue the
the riff one the one that supposed to
give that that one that gives you your
rift back when you're surrounded by
enemies right it's about to be on shout
out to seek freeze and those turret bros
about direct habit yo it's about to be a
problem because i'm gonna tell you right
now what's the new on the new forsaken
or oh yeah yes you talking about that
now lasting longer most likely but
that's not art so that's another way to
get it right right that's what the
grenade i believe right so now you're
talking getting a grenade one if you
have that this natural ability of
dealing your wrist by 600% by just
staying close and then everyone's
getting that riff
right if there any if there if you're
all you have other God isn't it this
could be I must say I'm saying right now
and I never say this I'm terrified of
this like this could be Loki breaking
the game but this sounds crazy to me am
i buggin does this sound crazy we'll see
I don't know I hope not but my and I'm
never one to complain about buffs and
I'm the listen I'm the person yeah if
you're sitting close together you get
your rift more often with the people or
under you pop your if do you have your
arc soul up and then you pop your if to
New York so up you pop your ft-ev your
so up and then if you run away your
Excel runs with you and then you got
your you fire up your art to it and then
you gots a riff back because your people
are backed by you and then it's like
yeah you're gonna be living in those
rifts a lot but I will say like mmm in
PvP I don't see riffs hardly ever like
rare moments do I see him so I mean
that's just like a class ability that
might get some more use but in PvE this
like this is absolutely give us a good
purpose to this build so yeah I guess
absolutely I mean I the way this is
going on well of Radiance might be in
trouble because if everybody's getting
arcs holes and you're helping the team
and everyone think about just right now
we think about doing the reckoning right
and you've got all those enemies around
you so shout out to the world of
warlocks who got the Vesper radius on
right you'll be getting ripped every
five seconds you're gonna be getting the
rift back the things gonna be lasting
longer everyone's gonna get the car to
what you call it it's about to be crazy
and then shout out one on one in the
crucible because getaway artist I've
been facing against Guardians we're
getting away artists right get away
artist is a problem like it does just
enough yeah you don't have to do as much
precise gunplay hmm
and that aux hole is on you he's only
that little turret is all you so um yeah
this this body is scary I love to tell
y'all right now ya better pay attention
this this is gonna get crazy
so anyway and then to my friend
void work in oval sinful oh it's been a
long time a long time notes clearly we
swung a bit hard let me hit this really
say
read that sitting right there we so long
a bit hard we took this time we analyzed
the data we knocked in the oh we did
it's hard how do you go through all the
analyzation that they go through and
then overdo it to where it's like hey
this is we shot it left it outside like
it's like it's been dead no one no one I
say one one person with me I'm the one
I'm the one oh no I try I'll be trying
to then but it's just like when they
swing that hard and that's why we've
talked about these like little
iterations of a like hey voidwalker is
really strong let's bring some of this
stuff down make a little shorter hey
it's still a little strong let's bring
some of this stuff down make a little
shorter do that little incremental stuff
over time so you don't have the swing
and a Miss or a swing and decapitation
like some balance in the middle like
maybe just like work it down work it
down just a little at a time so you find
the pace where you like hit the nail
flat and you don't break the board
yeah a way they went hard man we all we
know and um yeah surprisingly I was
using the super nerfed one recently and
um yeah it's a joke it's it's I mean you
maybe get like two kills people run away
anyway look at you about the new debuffs
so alright dishes serves as a nice
middle ground and settle into reduced
initial charge detonation energy costs
by 20% that's big reduced energy costs
by holding the charge detonation by 7%
okay reduced time required to fully
charge to charge that nation from 0.9 to
0.7 seconds okay redeeming chip all
about 20% for the full charge but still
though though though reduce dark blink
cost by 20%
like this absolutely and um increase
base super duration from 18 seconds to
22 seconds now actually that makes a
little difference because the way stands
right now post no you know post nerf
it's over so fast it's so fast so um
yeah man like I think this was
definitely needed you know voidwalker
definitely got hit way too hard no more
what got hit way too hard and it's good
to see now cuz they they have to have
the numbers no one's using it except me
so that was that just
you you have just me you know some unit
the other one the other void birth all
right dawn blade everlasting fire perk
so into the striker we want to make sure
this perk didn't allow for infinite
supers in certain activities when
increasing the amount you get back up
front but diminishing or put diminishing
returns on it so you can't go forever
this will be a super you can extend much
longer with skill tuned the amount of
super gain from everlasting fire initial
return increase from 10% to 13% super
energy return then decays literally over
the course of 30 kills from 13% to 0.75
percent return per kill and then it goes
into what you may be asking what about
spectral blades and then they go into
yeah I'll let you I'll let you touch
that I'll let you test with all those
like we know it's out of balance and
we're working on it right now
we have she tweaks to bring it back in
line well let you know the details once
we're finished play testing and locking
it back in throw some of them at us some
of them need to be in here like right
now like hey we have an idea okay
well if you have like we could be at
this spectrum do have do like 50% of the
changes right now or 50% of like
whatever numbers you're looking at just
to see how it feels to be like hey we're
gonna start here we are in the middle of
testing now if it's not quite right
we'll do it more but we know spectral
blades an issue so we want to address it
at this moment cuz you all hate it right
now know when's the next patch gonna
happen yeah says will let you know the
details once we finish play testing and
when that we don't be we don't know when
we finish play testing then we wait for
Oliver consoles approval then we get the
patches out so we have a date for it
what it's like but that's the time scale
that we look at on a lot of things and
they're not at that point yet so you say
like hey how's PvP spectral blade sucks
I can hit a spectral blades in the face
with a hammer of salt won't kill it yeah
it's crazy
it sucks I'm sorry you're invisible you
already have your advantage by roaming
new room yup fatty and super tough -
fits like I'm yours oh my god like so
much
so now spectral blades needs needs it
and they're like oh we're aware but not
yet again which leads me to believe if
they even mention it this to me in my
opinion screams tools it's taking much
longer to do
these type of changes for them and again
something they need to be concerned
about moving for for decreed yeah
absolutely
so won't beat the dead horse but yeah at
some point we'll see that change will
let you guys know what happens mmm patch
note review for two point two point one
which is come in on Tuesday with the art
would you catalysts I'm sorry wait are
these people what is happening right now
no new catalysts were actually coming
back in the game then is a miracle
mm-hmm dead red step one activate
spectral blades step two spam align
checks step three mean profit yes no
exotic weapon catalyst will be available
for new ones prospector so what it's
gonna do I just got it in a drop cuz I
can hold I don't know if there's
reserves or not I know at one point I
had nineteen grenades in there that's a
lot yeah
so I'm kind of curious what its gonna do
cuz that's the one where you it's Auto
fire and then when you release they
trigger all together right
mmm yeah yeah absolutely so I know you
wanna you want to give any idea take
what you do anything I'm hearing shout
out to pyro I mean there was some real
dirty things you could do with that
thing currently yeah yes a and I just
got it especially with the grenade
launcher buff mmm I don't know some type
of a AoE effect kind of thing may be
deeper reserves or something yeah that's
what I yeah cos kind of see the melon
that came is that is what I want to know
about because then we gonna stop right
there because the thing that I like that
d2 tried to do was stuff like racking
where they had these exotics where it's
like if everybody has one is gonna give
us some type of cool you're not I mean
like mechanic some bad buff and it's
quite really negligible it didn't really
you know you know aside from people
actually just doing real-world testing
they need something substantial if
everybody's rocking that racking
so yeah racking needs to get something
I'm very curious about that what what is
done with that hard light this is
honestly just
fun gun to use you know rain drop on an
auto rifle that can use all three damage
types I mean II I don't know if its
range isn't there so do you go stability
which it desperately probably needs a
part of yeah yeah we're clip size or
both I don't know if they take these to
a point of it being like more of a
unique catalyst perk because you take
something like or cliff coil in the
tracking improves that's a bit more
specific um or is it just gonna be like
a minor buff so we'll see yeah I heard
rumors are rumblings of minor stability
kind of dings probably I mean that's I'm
not holding my breath of these are gonna
be game breaking like or click oil
catalysts if you have it you definitely
need to grind that thing and I'm still
working on but it changes the way that
thing works yes other ones are more on
the minor side so we'll see suros regime
crucible whoa get that one into your
crucible matches that's gonna be trying
to think what that one would change yes
oh that's gonna be um they've hinted
somebody's already um that's gonna bleed
the percentage of health return back
edge right that's increased so it's
gonna almost have like a mini Crimson
field and Kranz in a little bit with
soros getting back to its glory be good
warlock blue mobility fixing the bloom
would not deal damage xur's inventory
will now offer random world perks for me
don't you roll past that don't you roll
past no not like that's one of theirs
for like if you had three homes the
perks are the same on all three
everything goes and I don't know the
whole randomness I'm like something's
not and this is what speaking of their
randomness my brother and I were like
playing and we'll do a point where like
hey we both turned in this thing at the
same time and we both get the exact same
thing yes way whatever their RNG is
calculated on I know RNG can only be so
much in literally computer it's ones and
zeroes you have to set some type of
algorithm mathematical equation whatever
it is but I swear there's has to be
based on a clock somewhere something
like a second like you know 943 in 27
seconds and then it multiplies by this
because when my brother and I do it at
the same time of latency like seconds
we're like I got the same thing how is
that that shouldn't even be remotely
possible
yeah or if I tried to back-to-back same
thing happens like the double stacks
happen too frequently in this game so
mm-hmm there's not as much RNG in this
world shout the Vagabond oh into chat
he's saying I'm surgery which basically
think about when you get you know an
Armour piece think about skull of
diamond car like the perks that's on it
already preset you know like some may
have like machine gun reserves some may
have you know super energy or you know
faster shooting with this weapon instead
of it being no set perks all the time
each week he'll actually offer different
subsets of perks on those exotics armors
and stuff like that so that's pretty
much what he means and it's good for
synergy is good for synergy with bills
and stuff like that because I have
exotics that I use all the time and
unfortunately because I keep getting
that same you know how you stun the law
for example so I would really like you
know machine gun reserves on that one
you know kind of deal so that's what it
shot the fact one and they've had a lot
of they've had a lot of sniper and
machine-gun perks on there
and sadly I feel like those are about to
go away yeah so check this weekend we'll
see in about two hours what he's got
mm-hmm a couple infusion pieces not the
perk that we all want changed but the
bow and the Bray tech can be infused
higher now if you really really wanted
it mostly the bat was the only one I'd
worry about mm-hm gambit prime weapons
will now have a chance to drop as match
completion awards from gambit prime
increasing drop baits for gambit prime
weapons from the reckoning both gambit
prime and the reckoning will have
increased or operates for weapons after
completion without a drop until players
are guaranteed a reward so mmm-hmm
getting better efforts in there for
making your time better spent so yes
agreed a game but prime and invasion
will heal so here we go yeah baby was
gamma prime an invasion will heal 8% of
the perennials health down from 12 yes
so that's smaller the invasion
portal cooldown now this is kind of a
big deal the invasion portal cooldown
time during the primeval phase will be
increased to 40 seconds up from 30 yeah
and the cooldown triggers after the
player has been killed or successfully
returns from invasions so yes yes yes
yeah seriously I mean that's absol
it needed to happen and it basically
means is like it felt like the timer
would start as soon as they invade or
when the portal key like whenever the
whole process started because then
they'd come back and then there'd be a
point where if I'm in a full invasion
the whole time and I get you know come
back through and I'm running back out I
feel like I can almost invade pretty
quick again and you could just do it
over and over
mmm so annoying
that's the part about gammatron that I
was getting on my nerves were just like
you'd only comment and interrupt you
know the thing they just felt like they
just can keep coming back like
especially if you killed them like yo
come on man like if I'm 200 in the 30
yeah there should be an event it just
extends the match because remember the
whole thing about Gambhir promise must
be all it's one round remember it's one
round it's gonna be quick in and out
what's he hiding it round my butt
exactly it is so long drawn-out you know
and it again to kill I like the kills
will heal 8% you know again it helps but
like you know to people like if you got
if you're going against a team that has
could invade a good invader like man
like Oh demoralizing til moralizing so I
like these changes it's not gonna be as
invasion dominant you know it's still
gonna be effective but I like I like
this man this is this is really cool in
the lore and one of the bottom camber
problem now came to unlock the weekly
game a clean and Graham I'm like of
course it's gambit as it should be
question bounties power surge bounties
that have been deleted or expired will
be back they are per character use
one-time only and yes sir I'm closer by
the way this is an annoying bounty I'll
explain in a second will now reward four
points for a win in 2.0 big difference
mmm so I actually didn't read this quite
the same way because I thought it was
still the same it will award four points
for win and two points for a loss with
an involution value of 20 points as
opposed to award three for a win deduct
two for a loss yeah that was pretty
brutal
and then the worst part about that was
when I did it I got a plus one powerful
drop mm-hmm not a plus 3 plus 4 plus 2
plus one I'm like I'm sorry this one
takes me a lot more than like oh I don't
know
a flash point or an adventure so yeah
that was yeah the weight on powerful
Ingram still never feels quite right all
four weekly roll boundaries for a game
for prime now grant powerful helmet
Awards as they should
yes sir there shouldn't be too much
downtime when they roll out the patch
next week basically if you're just in
the game still they're probably gonna
make you kick out to restart but I'm not
gonna have them on screen you but the
emotes of arc yo yeah I don't know if
I'm gonna have to buy all these things
or how we're gonna get them but I won
them all I want them all I also want to
know if they would make solar and void
but these are like the hunter just
twirling the staff and his fire and you
got the Titan just like crushing his
hands mm-hmm the Warlock just like you
know holding up the OL diamond of energy
they're they're just cool I'll be
hitting test Everest
it got my credit card ready by the
silver help what's the biggest package
you get oh you got you got that bonus on
50 no I'm just gonna yeah that's getting
purchase buddy I'm saying it right there
he's the one if not all cuz those are
just I hate it when they do cool emotes
I hate it and that's the thing it's like
and this is where I'm like I'm okay like
how much money am I getting out of the
Annual Pass I still play a but on a
destiny it's like if I drop 20 bucks on
a couple emotes because they're almost
the awesome and I can use it and it
looks sick cool hmm it's a cosmetic and
this is always the thing it's still a
cosmetic it's completely optional if you
don't want to buy it don't feel
obligated but they look cool and they're
tempting you and that just means they
did a good job in their marketing it
well so they're doing their job and
they're a private studio now there's one
of the biggest Indies in the world they
got to pay for their way they got
incredibly invasive bills man listen man
we got to help out the Indian II created
small developers in the game right now
gotta help out these small baby indie
developers with hundred million dollar
Nettie's infusions and
we gotta help ma man is tough out here
these indie streets they said there has
been okay so here's the big topic
because they kind of touched on in the
end they had the TV piece they had the
not PvP but that's what I was gonna talk
about they had the gambit stream by the
way I didn't even kiss the stream but I
heard on the other to gambit prime
streams but the basically Bungie was
wrecking people I don't know I don't PC
because I think you got a little more
the hardcore sweat he's there I'll be
curious to see what the record was but
mm-hmm the thieves got ahead of
everything there's been a lot of rumors
running around a lot of videos being
made a lot of speculation is PDP going
to continue in destiny and needs
straight-up came out in the beginning of
a stream and then posted something up
later and said there are people upstairs
right now on working on the evolution of
crucible and what the future of crucible
will be like whether it's Maps whether
its modes I can't say anything right now
as to what it is that I'm not revealing
content at this point but crucible is
not going anywhere
anybody just clarified it like that and
I was just like good that's one of the
better points where you actually know
that this has been basically this week
and when all the stuff has been starting
to fly around and for them to come up
and just come out and say it it's like
they do have their ear to the ground
even if they're tone-deaf on in fusion
cores which yes that was really de UT
the sneakers today give the cheetah a
Snickers he's going make the day baby
continue no I'm B but that's the point
you know they listen so it's like that's
one of those pieces that like netis to
it's like I feel like said for an
evolution of crucible into their purest
version of it gambit though what about a
battle royale oh don't I mean it would
it would be I'd love to I wish in their
dev environment on a network on some
crazy computer that they've got sitting
there some networked machine I want to
see what that looks like like 20 golden
gunshots firing across I just
back to my mic you got like Nova bombs
slowly drifting back and forth past each
other that engine would break the minute
this boy sure like why do you avoid it
oh it's green like the first like the
patch goes live you cue into the battle
royale and as soon as the first game
goes live and everybody's like queued up
as soon as everybody starts to fire
their supers at about the same time
Bellevue catches on fire exactly with
two generations away from a game of this
fidelity love doing battle battle doing
their battle royal
yes knew it I can ask no but what are
you like so what do you first what do
you feel about the whole hey everybody's
gonna take a hype train room or like a
not a high train but a rumor and run
with like everybody made their videos
and then they come out and say it it's
like were you worried would you think
about it like what do you what do you
think on this overall and just kind of
where people are coming from that there
hasn't been a lot of PvP content in the
Sanyo guess they're still doesn't look
like there's similar much you have Josh
Hamrick you have two people leaving like
there was a lot like that was like
thrown like this there's a lot on the
wall but laying so woody what do you
think of this whole thing going down
listen I don't think people were
overreacting I think the concern was
legitimate I listen the rumor again on a
base level if you took it for what it
was and then you looked at the evidence
surrounding the rumor right you had
crucible guys you went with new ski
hammer it these are lead guys you know
saying gone you know we haven't had
sandbox updates in forever
crucible azzaman touch Trials cancelled
you know from the crucible community a
home we feel like yo like y'all just
completely abandon us and then given us
an attitude of we have no more discuss
at this time we don't know when we're
gonna do it but we're you know we're
getting rid of it so heavy concern then
we heard those leaks about d3 and you
know what it's supposed to be and how
they're supposed to be going away from
BP like it was snowballing and again
normally these type of things I don't go
crazy but in this case yes I fell victim
yes I'm like cuz you know what it was I
think it was
I was at PAX and then you hit me I was
talking to Laura
my name is by shout out to Mike but ever
but I'll stop with him and then you hit
me you like yo where's new ski and I'm
like really hammer it both I'm like what
is going on with the restructuring over
there like why are they getting rid of
crucible guys it only adds to it so I'm
so glad the each of these guys got in
front of it because you know people were
getting that Sherlock Holmes on and I
was def definitely one of them so people
love the crucible shout to fall out
plays shout to ask asked across gaming
both had fantastic videos listen is
crucible in the greatest place no is it
more things they can do yes but this is
a feature and you know how like I was on
the division train and the reason why I
was on the division train because I'm
like at the end of the day they have
features for everybody even if there's
people who do not like dark zone do not
like crucible in destiny there are
people that do love it and you want that
extension when it give people options
and things to do and to take away an
option and make it a complete you know
PvE game you know it's like that it's
almost Borderlands right boy bands has
that Lane you know mean kind of again
you know I understand people's the
counterpoint which is in terms of
balancing you have to balance twice that
kind of a bit but at the end of the day
don't I'm a firm believer a gaming do
not take away features that you yourself
introduced because to me that's like
it's a bad look it's it's like false
advertising I used to get that way with
sport
what's game come out they'd be all these
great features like oh wow then I can't
wait for next year
and then you're like wait a minute what
happened to that feature like I used to
love that why can't I do this anymore
and there's no talk about it right so
yeah shout out the gauge shout out to
the team we needed to hear that we made
it together so hopefully it should
settle everybody down you know come t3
or whatever they have planned in the
next couple of seasons opulence or what
have you you know we start to get a
little bit more light on what they
really intend on doing because they do
seem to I will say this they do seem to
be struggling though with the direction
of where they want to go
Yeah right I really their soul yeah they
definitely seem to be still struggling
with that but as long as we hear that
it's not going away
people can breathe a sigh relief yeah
that's what I got and that's one piece I
think about too that they've got to
figure out for crucible and PvE they got
to figure out a way to separate them
they have to find some way especially
either going into d3 to handle in a
different way jumping with my brother
about this but it was like even if you
take a point like okay so if you want to
balance pvp and PVE and your world about
like nerfing stuff too much in PvE but
then you have a gun you take into PvP
and it's too good like if I had just a
go figure and I went into PvP what if it
had no person was just a go figure but
if I go into PvE all those perks are
active ooh interesting
so I'm a just in sub what I mean that's
one of about a thousand different ideas
everybody probably has but you have to
find your way to separate those two like
I think destiny without crucible for one
cuz it's an allure it's literally part
of the Lord using your ghost you got
checks like it's all in there you can't
just strip that away and even if I don't
always love it there are moments I still
go in there and I have some fun and it
is a part of and it is part of the game
it's part of the rotation and there's
too many people who still like there's
part of your community that keeps this
game alive because of PvP so I don't
think removing it
what a smart like that wouldn't be good
and you know some people just have
different points in their life and it
seems like you know hammer can was new
ski they're probably friends anyone be
like oh really
they're just probably talking to you
like we've been in this for like I don't
know wolf years we done we're gonna take
a break through something else it's like
and they're you mean those points or
it's just like hey we're looking at
doing these things who knows but it was
like I'm glad he said it it's like I
want to see them find some way to work
on separation if not in d2 because the
engines probably still stuck basically
where it's at but made hopefully knee
three some type of way when it comes to
the future
to figure out what's going on and
speaking of the future we got some leaks
about what's coming in oh yeah smaller
learning if you don't care about leaks
you don't want to see what's out there
this is all speculation from people
who've put information out before some
of it reliable some of it may not but
this is what
gonna talk about at this point so if you
guys do want to skip this you are more
than welcome to but we're going to be
talking about leaks and speculation of
what is to come
boiler alert indeed so first we know we
have season of opulence coming got a
raid and got a six player mate match
made activity which I still have no idea
what it is and then we're gonna have you
know one more exotic quest in there and
all those pieces are gonna be doing
their thing mm-hmm
we don't know what's after that now the
timing of that is season of opulent
starts in June so we're gonna have
seasonal opulence before III starts okay
right
III is gonna come mm-hmm
there is no Sony stage correctly not
there but typically they're probably
gonna do their own thing before or maybe
you know this is their time to do their
own thing or Lenny three day down do it
the week later whatever they do they're
probably gonna do it on their own
timing for what comes next now the rumor
and speculation is there will be no
comet type major expansion but
potentially a year three Annual Pass
they said the but they said the first
DLC or first piece of the Annual Pass
will be significantly bigger than you
know like season The Drifter or season
in the forge so not taking king I heard
not even rise of iron but bigger and
that's kind of the point where was like
right so hardened wasn't huge mmm
but you have season of opulence with a
raid a six-person match made activity
and exotic quest so it's like they're I
don't know what big and small is I don't
know if it's like season of opulence
with a raid probably that isn't gonna be
impressive if they do a raid and raid
back-to-back though because I don't know
if they've actually done a June raid and
they September 8th one would think they
would have to based on the significance
of September or whatever month they
decide to drop that's the other question
if it's an annual pass then it is
probably gonna be September so they keep
it steady and
they take these three as long as they
can so I mean this yeah that kind of
furs most most of what's year three what
do you what do you think what do you
feel give me your give me your overall
gonna kind of give me some speculation
on your end
yeah I mean listen though the source
tends to be valid
all right it's a good uh good old buddy
anon so um you know when I read it you
know part of me was like okay III
anticipate opulence being solid I really
do you know I'm saying I think the law
behind it is strong I think having an
array should be strong to get resolution
um you know me you've gone back and
forth as far as how the future what the
future holds and you know you know in a
post Activision less world for them and
um you know it's one of those things
where it's just like I get it when I
hear rumors at an angle you guys I was
not that thrilled II when I heard and
you'll pass again I'm lying
oh you know we're not done with this yet
but the reception let's be real like
season pass reception I got a caller how
it's been very mediocre right it has
some points where you like yeah I'm
excited to play this week yadda yadda
yadda then as I am you know you're just
dragging stuff out now you're unlocking
a different difficulty yada yada yada um
you know again so now you're saying more
of the same which is again trip feed and
then I gotta be honest II you you
dropped the ball more me about September
and I may have reacted emotionally about
your bomb which is the borderlands yeah
and I admit being that packs being not
the most hardcore borderlands guy I
recognize the game is fun and I did play
part two and I had a good time with two
but I came I was late into the series
right and I understand that is the
Godfather the og I get the whole thing
right and people even with don't trail
and messing up to three times in that
place people were going crazy like I
could feel the floor shake yeah that's
how crazy the anticipation was and I
gotta be real like as much as it's not
my thing
I have to be cognizant that this is a
rabid fan base and for them to drop in
September with my beloved potential
destiny we could have problems I got it
thinking I was like maybe I responded
too emotionally to eat stain effects
that's right Dusty's gonna say and I'm
like strong this place right now you
know I mean it's okay you're doing
better you just think about some of the
bigger streamers for destiny bro man get
a lien huge for Orleans people mm-hmm
nah it's so gonna be a brand new lunar
shooter it's like you know a lot of
people in this lunar shooter space that
have gone to play anthem gone to play
visions gone to play guess what's next
for aliens three yeah and and I'll say
well I'll cut you one part you want to
say one more good I think this is gonna
have the effect that I thought anthem
would have one destiny mmm
we thought anthem would be the
distraction game right that would be the
game that you jumping you jump out with
your friends your buddies PvE focus
whatever whatever we'll get into the
development stuff we got a lot to talk
about that but Borderlands has a refined
history right Borderlands has is the og
of the looters shooter and it's been
sold and his highly anticipated so them
dropping in that month there's a little
bit of a gauntlet throwing down and
that's Destiny's month let's keep it up
let's keep it all September everybody
knows destiny comes out but I'm gonna
throw it in name of us say what you
gonna do new that you Gordon
rich we out here the grunge is out what
you gonna do that doesn't fit challenge
man that's a big dude Duke does does
destiny blink they by heaven I do Yui
I'm a little nervous you gotta be diggin
I got out of my feelings tata packs i
responded she to fast because i was
anything either not know that's the I'm
not worried about that's Tina then I
thought about I'm like who he might be
right on this what have I been
whoo talk to me talk to me for delay is
great I mean this is this is where
Bungie has their decisions to make these
are rumors these are speculation but as
you've said what do you do for a year
it is Tippit's a potentially a live
service game my argument with you know
my brother going back and forth is do
you do yeah it's like said Fred said
people secretaries on it it's like the
anthem was unknown people know
Borderlands and how it plays so they
know you're coming so that's one of
those three those pieces of it's it's a
real threat yeah they spent enough time
they haven't forced it they're like
we're announcing it now we're doing this
thing it's been in development for a
while we're gonna get a gameplay demo
coming up in a month or something like
that and see what it looks like and that
gameplay demo is gonna be months away
from launch and you know it's months
away from not like here's a demo that's
a beta in a game that's broken and we'll
talk about that later let's there they
weren't gonna do this without like being
ready and they're not gonna pick
September without being ready so I mean
it's a real threat but also you have the
Annual Pass model smaller mountain you
have potentially four sections of it
because you don't have your forsaken
piece of it mmm but I guess the other
piece is how much and I've said this is
where I go back like how good does d3
have to be at this point
to pull people away from everything that
they're doing um very good like it has
to be freaking nine out of ten easy to
be like I'm gonna stop playing all these
other things there's a year's worth of
free content for Division two anthem
hasn't stopped being developed even if
it was a train wreck beforehand they're
trying and give them a year like see
what they're able to do maybe they even
release a you know loot 2.0 or some
crazy thing you have all these pieces
building towards and guess what you have
new consoles probably gonna be launching
at the same time the d3
gonna be coming out they're not gonna be
the only thing hallo infinite it's gonna
be a thing probably mm-hmm at lunch like
d3 has to swing for the absolute fences
and actually hit the home run out of the
park because if they swing and miss one
she is in huge trouble because that's a
they are independent the risk is on them
now so sure if they do an annual pass
this is a long build sorry if they do
the annual pass it lets them focus on
what's next it lets the live team keep
some things afloat keep little drip feed
you know me write in a random article
about this
oh here's sees another you know season
drifter hey Hawk moon came back
hey this is here like these little
things keep coming to keep it as you
said barely there some little presence
of the mind but it's not a huge
development cycle piece like comets
where they have to pull away from d3 cuz
that has to be their focus and I think
at that point that d3 has to be amazing
because they burn people on d1 you lost
some there burn people on d2 year one
for sync and brought some back but not
everybody this is your like your number
three like Halo 3 being its epic piece
your destiny 3 has to be your swan song
because at that point you have to do it
right your 10 year plan this is what
you're probably gonna wrap it on oh look
at he bought his right now smirking I
don't like this I like when you get you
away because this is you saying see
everything this is your d3 spiel and you
love this you love this you love the
fact that it's like okay we're gonna
trip feed it out we gotta just stay
relevant we're gonna do this and then we
got guns blaze 53 okay I mean you have
you have a set number of resources
however you divide them up you can't
make a forsaken level experience and
still be working on d3 in the next year
a full game takes years to make mmm they
gotta be a hardcore into that
development so what do you know you know
I listen I understand that the train of
thought I understand what you're saying
I think that there's well if you look at
it from a resource standpoint and then
being on their own
I could understand the argument I could
understand like yo we got a d3 is all or
nothing
you know will drip feed again it's just
like it's tough for me man I struggle
because long term your plan is probably
the correct in the safest plan
definitely I worry about being banal
snapped like I worry about look right
now in my opinion they're shredding
water hate reading you know I'm saying
they just going it's not terrible
we're not cursive Osiris days right no
it's reading cool little gun here cool
little quest here cool a little bit
but are we really stopping people from
playing Division I would really stop you
even yourself playing Sakura right you
know any any new thing that comes out
people hate new things out you know I'm
saying like so again I get concerned
when there's not the Forsaken there's
not the taken King where it says no
you're playing destiny and that's all
you gonna play because we're doing
boombastic things and it's gonna be this
big chunk of content and stuff like that
you know season our plants we have to
see you know they go back now again
here's the other thing we still don't
know when the release of annual passes
because now they're gonna be according
to the rumor they're gonna be debuting
and you'll pass again yeah but the
question is when do they I mean I guess
it's annual pass maybe you survive
September but boy Lance is coming
there's no that boy Lance is gonna come
it's gonna have a cataclysmic effect
it's already breaking the internet on
all the different formats and way in it
epic store it all it's all stuff you
know I'm saying so it's coming you know
I I just worry I just worry about
because if you're not strong and you
given us black armory 2.0 random you
know say drift is cool I like it you
know is it's okay I mean I'm not I'm not
I'm not like thrilled at all I'm really
doing is grin but all but I like the
reckoning you know I'm saying no rain
it's again it's like you see I'm saying
is like with shredding these things you
like these things you don't yeah it's
nothing that's going to make you stop
everything you're doing and I think they
kind of need that now in your dish
fence they're claiming that it's not
gonna be common but they recognize the
importance of the first part of this
annual pass and that it will be
something substantial they've got to do
something they got to do something cool
maybe that's when they bring Aldrin back
into the fold you know we'll get
something with that you know we got
Sabbath on you know I don't know I mean
we got a lot of things they're sitting
on I just get worried man I just get
worried but um as far as the rumors I
know we're gonna get back into there you
know from what I'm hearing you know
about these about the story and stuff
like that and in the space debris no
sounds very cool you know we got some
lore that that kind of leads into that
um we got to see man this is this is
again I thought they were doing fine
because I was like okay Hampton cottage
off the ball they survived that out
division is division it got his hardcore
thing but not jesting I feel like dusty
placing Division players are still kind
of different people right I mean
especially if sci-fi and yeah person
first first I mean they're their
memories I mean yes they're both looter
shooters but that's kind of where the
similarities stop right you don't say so
um shot the wall blackjack he say he
betting on a Rosenbach sighs yeah I
would love that man I would love a Raza
Ryan 2.0 you know I mean we got a C man
I'm nervous though I'm nervous come
September I gotta see it's gotta be the
way you feel about how D three has to be
that's how I feel about this first part
of and yeah I think that's it it cannot
be that big and that's you worry getting
they know Chanel so here's the thing
you're talking about and this is
literally what I think they want to try
and do in 2020 you're saying hey there's
this new game pulling people like hey
there's this new game pulling in people
away why can't they be low-key give that
level support give the Annual Pass if
you want to keep playing something when
you why not have a d3 to be like hey d3
if they come out and they do it right
you don't think people are gonna come
back to the big number to be like a
fresh start
no I'm gonna tell you what people are
burned with this game it's this game is
like well if they burned if they're
burned with d2 then how you you can't
win them back by doing another
destiny to something they're already
saying it's destiny - I'm done with
whatever that is so your only real way
to try and pull them back as go three
full new light if you want somebody
playing destiny you can't just be like
annual pass or bigger expansion or
expansion it's still t3 and if
somebody's playing destiny - I don't
want to start at zero to try and get up
to level a thousand what you mean what
you mean break that back or instead of
level 700 right now if you go through
annual pass I bet you because we're
getting at 750 you're probably going to
go 750 to 800 750 to 850 and the other
three seasons will be or 800 850 950 900
950 you'll be end up at a thousand as my
guess
my hunch for power levels for the next
year sorry spoiler alert now I'm scared
but if somebody comes in and says hey
it's like this thing came out in
September well you have your character
and you're gonna go do this even if you
do your power boost bounties people eyes
is it still dusty - yeah so like how
much different is it and it's not even
that big like even if it was like how
much did four say can get you said
Forsaken has been lower on sales than
even Activision was hoping for okay good
- I'll let you know but like no but like
Activision may have lofty crazy
expectations that's fine and they did
but also in turn the number of people
who bought destiny is not a hundred
percent of people who bought who bought
forsaken it's a smaller number because
you had smaller chunk fell off smaller
chunk fell like Osiris was like kaboom
and then some people were like at war
mind was okay and then Forsaken may have
been some but you're probably already
working with 50% of the people who
started playing destiny - and then if
you go okay this is another expansion on
this one even if it's late for one
trying to do a force akin to a forsaken
isn't easy
they need some time to build something
real letting rise of iron was okay but a
bit not everybody who played sd1 was
playing rise of iron you have this
trickle off destiny - was one of the big
sales you have that big leap again and
that's the point where I feel like des
d3
needs all like it it's the best chance
it has is my baby
I think destiny is the best chance
destiny has to figure out whenever they
want to launch it don't have a sit now
to a hey this is a crazy Call of Duty
hey this is Grand Theft Auto 6 don't put
it near any of that crazy stuff what if
you do like you know brand new if they
can actually pair that thing with a
console lunch and say hey this is like a
first month game the hype to go along
with that one I think d3 is the best
shot that this franchise has to survive
I don't think an annual pass or even
another forsaken expansion is what is
gonna allow Bungie to keep the lights on
I mean we just we had a funnel
yeah we're a difference of opinion yeah
we have a difference of being it um yeah
I mean I again I mean it's one of those
things that I don't think what you're
saying is per se wrong I just I just
worry that you know the way I look at
destiny is like this this this
girlfriend in love with and she
continues to cheat on hey how many times
right are you going to say I'm gonna
stay lawyer I'm gonna listen to what you
have to say and all this other stuff
because other stuff is out here I like
at some point the games got to stay
attractive the games got to stay attract
the games got to still make you want to
if we say you know what
alright you go in the corner you do your
drip-feed content you know gamers are
not loyal man gamers are not loyal they
will back away from that game and it's
already in a kind of state and I will
say this yes
you know Activision felt that way about
for Sega but you can't say for a fact
like the impact forsaken had or bringing
people back and just engagement in
general yeah they had ridiculous sales
number actively they want something else
but let's not act like it wasn't a
success it was a tremendous it galvanize
we were doing last wish raid like it was
insane it was vintage Bungie and I've
never seen the community so happy and I
had people who were casual saying yo is
it safe you know is it okay I'm not
y'all it's safe get in here the ward is
nice you know I mean if you black armory
this thing up for a year people are not
loyal they are gonna be like same Oh
destiny that's that crap no no no you've
got to make it sexy
you've got to make it attractive you've
got to always put in your face y'all but
agree that we go go okay but again like
how much resources does it take to do
that they don't have all the support and
they can't put a desk no choice
they got no pro this is there's a limit
somewhere do you want destiny 3 or do
you want destiny to 5k we have no - I
can't I can't we have it they don't have
enough people say they flat out don't
have enough people do you lost hi moon
part of that creation
you lost Vicarious Visions part of that
creation they're on them trying to
support a game that they have live and
trying to make like whatever comes next
you're talking realistic stuff and
everything you're saying is true guess
what gamers don't care
gamers don't care they're gonna say
that's nice but that content is mediocre
you're giving me mediocre content I want
my socks that people they don't want to
hear about it it's sad ok so what I want
everything you see what I want them to
come out and say is this is weird we're
a separate studio now we don't have
Activision and in our backs matter
otherwise I want them to say and what we
want to do is put most of our work force
on d3 so what we're gonna I want them to
come out and say this like verbatim how
it looks meant to be like they can say
whatever they like the content trash
people not playing you contact me but
that's fine the hardcore can help
sustain the next year to keep them
afloat while they work on do a lot you
asking a lot bro but I'm just saying how
are you gonna let me say well that's my
country what is a day do you think a
forsaken right now would one people back
after the Annual Pass if it's forsaken
any old pass or people are gonna be like
am I really gonna go down that road
again but a little bit you say something
good you cut out I may go there do you
think do you think right now of people
plan destiny to forsaken really cool
annual best do you think right now after
the annual pass may have turned some
people off or turn people away that even
a forsaken level in September would
bring people back on do yes enough yes
no you know I don't forget forsaken
forsaken was amazing if you're getting a
Polish you're also starting to spread
people thinner and thinner and thinner
your history sources no no I'm talking
about gamers you
division you have anthem you have
Borderlands you have all these other
things that I'm like give it space give
it like that's so how much budget like
yeah gambit prime like how many people
lost like C is the drift to be like I'm
gonna go do the vision now now they're
hooked on division okay they're got a
year of content with that shot at the
Forte I'm part of the hardcore and I
won't come back from that's what I'm
trying to take the hardcore is not that
thrill okay so Forte here's the question
will you come back for d3 but your bet
here's the thing you gotta make it to d3
you you got you're acting like it's a
guaranteed homerun they do d3
everybody's like yeah we're bad no but
if they're not putting out quiet it's a
result business if you're not putting
out quality aim can hinge okay so look
at games that no look that's the
situation they put themselves in no
that's the reality unfortunately it may
not be realistic you're right there it's
not really here
well no company can do that no company
continued to be like forsaken forsaken
forsaken every DLC for Sega but I'm
saying like a comet level obviously
we're not doing forsaken opulence right
we still expect you know it's not gonna
be for a second level expects maybe
you're in the middle you don't say any
kind of thing it's not gonna be crazy
but September I'm telling you eat if
they come out with eight a 2.0 Marah is
economy crap and spread it out a week
here in a week there and oh here's
here's hot moon and oh here's this old
thing I'm telling you right now people
gonna roll their eyes and be like okay
and then you see what you're saying is
like great right cuz they can bank up
they're gonna charge up and it's d3 and
it's yeah d3 come out and people gonna
be like Emma even I'm telling you that's
how fickle gamers are you I'm not saying
it's realistic you're right
it's I'm not saying it is it maybe maybe
that's just the reality maybe it just
can't be done and I wouldn't accept that
but god dammit you gonna have to try you
don't have to get all hands on deck you
gonna have to buy some you don't want to
link up you got to do something cuz it
I'm telling you right now they're not
going to survive with this
structured its annual pass dripped
little crumbs and what would you kind of
goal so if your limited resources would
you'd rather have no annual pass or and
or would you rather have like a
September and nothing say this is how
you have to split it up because you're
limbing you're limited in some way to
call of duty takes three years to make
they have three different Studios doing
it now you have one trying to continue
to put out crazy levels of content then
they can't now that's why I was like
that's a point where a Bungie comes out
and says we are focused on destiny three
right now what we're gonna plan to do is
a similar situation we're gonna give you
guys Italy you know shot in the arm in
September or whatever but also like say
you do so what say if like rise of iron
and Borderlands three came out in
September a week apart
how long is one gonna last versus the
other when destiny two is like destiny
to 2.8 versus Borderlands 3 oh my god
like which one's gonna which one's gonna
pull right so it means the time because
Devon or focus on what's next yes no
that's not a great white flag waving the
white flag you're busy say we can't
compete with donde - oh so let's not
dwell I'm not saying give up I'm saying
we're gonna go like don't put out
something mediocre focus on your next
iteration and that's the big focus well
if you saw the next mission
then what's currently going to come out
is going to be media because based on
the resources available right and that's
and that gives people that gives the
people that are like hey it's like I'm
gonna spend I still want to play dusty
so I'm gonna spend 20 or 30 bucks I'm up
in now in there and they might get some
money from an annual pass it is an
annual pass so they're getting it all up
front fine but the piece is like there's
a point where people have to breathe on
these games I'm playing sucker oh you
jump in division we try anthem we're
gonna try other things why you playing
Sakura why are you now playing destiny
why are you not playing destiny let's be
real because it's did Clark it is
mediocre but if you can't realistically
ask for that [ __ ] forever I'm sorry
Lakewood [ __ ] otherwise yeah it's a sad
world man there's a sad world it's okay
we just got done reading the damn
article about developers who would
through absolute hell you can't pass
that of them
the developers sake I've okay then
respect the games that go play something
else that's nice did you feel that way
let them focus on something that can
actually serve them okay if they're oh
you have two options one and two you
have destiny - we're never even gonna
get to the other stuff you have destiny
- oh no I have my hands up literally
like a fight I gotta get my legs
involved a kickboxer you have an annual
pass that is gonna give them a little
bit of something people are probably
gonna jump in the tryout the dados the
hardcore will probably do a little bit
of something here and there you have des
d3 that has to get made they have you
keep saying the engine isn't there
do you still want do you still want
destiny - Forsaken - whatever you want
to call it in this same engine with the
slow cycles or would you rather them
build this next thing again you have to
you can't have both
why not because there is not enough of
them around there's not enough Bungie to
do both here's the thing you can do both
if you change structure this is what I'm
offering like you don't have to do
aerial pass again you could literally do
comet and chill yeah you could do
comment be in the news cycle have a ton
of content and chill ride back to the
end of the what is it 2019 and then wait
2020
whenever the new next generation
consoles come boom you can do that you
can dream up things you could show you
can't make d3 in nine months
you can't roll that's these four his
nine is the problem with your theory and
yes we're fighting chat oh here's the
problem
you're basically what you're saying in
2019 all you're giving me is drip-feed
that means we're not gonna have any
substantial content for a whole year
no Forsaken no taken king drip drip drip
drip drip okay how was the diet is a
recipe for disaster in my drink how
happens droughts in the st1 how did the
droughts and destiny one get taken
hey see god they had but they had rods
of iron they had that wasn't what those
times in between that you're saying do a
rise of iron and nothing right
how did that go over I'm gonna tell you
right now I'll take taking king and a
drought versus all this crap we're
dealing with right now I'm sorry this is
not the way it is sounded cool we wanted
to give them a shot but you can't tell
me you are honestly as enthused as you
were during that period of take it we
have so much to do during that period
now it's like I'm not saying we're not
so again this is a point where they have
to decide yeah they have they're at a
crossroads of like where do we put our
focus in it for second is not an easy
thing to make taking King is not an easy
thing to make absolute not easy things
to make those are large pieces of
content that is not quite a d3 but it's
Forsaken was damn close to world's full
do subclasses art design length sub
clock so much stuff in there you can't
do anything close to that again and have
focus on why not I already covered it
all so because at some point you have to
let other then work on it you have to
let people work on something else you
can't always have like 50/50 and be like
hey we're gonna continue to support and
this other teams over here just let him
go gung-ho let them take up everybody
wants everybody is so used to this style
of destiny to it guess what is probably
about to change activision doesn't say
you have to put out in september you
have to put out in september you have to
put out in September that calendars not
forced upon them so now it's a point
where if they're like hey how do we want
to function as a company that's what
Luke Smith said and the one gambit in
the game of prime video we're still
trying to figure out how we want to do
this
mm-hm and they know d3 is in its timing
you know what's been being worked on
these paid 160 million dollars to get
that IP and that's what I'm saying I
don't think they're going away but I was
like I think d3 is if the rumor is
roughly there if it is an annual pass
which seems like I don't think they have
anything in a front loaded annual pass
but still something it's just to a point
where I think des t3 is their best shot
to bring people you're not gonna bring
people back even forsaken being good did
not bring everybody who bought
- back if destiny - and curse of Osiris
my hardcore buddy gamer did not play war
mind did not my war mine because cursors
Osiris sucked so bad after you burned
burned war mind was a forsaken really
cool but not ever so a shot we just keep
everybody dissatisfied we should wait
till next year wait till next year y'all
is gonna be better don't we you're not
happy now you're not gonna be happy
wait till 2020 and we got you and you're
gonna come back in droves because you've
been so satisfied the whole year that is
not going to work these people are not
loyal man only us only the last word
will sit here and we'll do our show
we'll talk about the content we'll have
a great time about the things that
they're adding but the hardcore gun I
mean that the casuals are the people
that you really need to get back I don't
know man
I don't know get casuals pack with a
expansion 2.8 I don't think you get
casuals back with that I don't think
those the well I don't think those are
the ones you win back in in September
you don't win people back there - like
I'm kind of done with destiny oh this is
another expansion on destiny - I'm not
getting it the casual person is not
gonna say I'm gonna go get destiny to
void or whatever you want to call the
damn thing they're not gonna jump out be
like this is another expansion of what I
played two years it's still not the new
one yet it's not it's not gonna be what
pulls it in there to me if I'm a casual
if I'm a casual gamer that's not I mean
how many people played ERISA fire and
how many people play taken King it was
probably taking king or like destiny -
or destiny taking King probably wasn't
everybody but a lot and it was good and
then some people back home and that was
but the end of rise of iron was like
okay but it's like no but no I know I'm
not saying any of these pieces of
content or trash I'm just saying there's
a point where people no matter if you
love the game or not do not stick with
these things forever they're like hey I
need a level of consistent you under to
see between taking King and rise of mine
there's still a high there's still those
were not the same role you may need to
tell me you're gonna equate the period
between taking King and rise around
between the period between or the the
armoury the black armory is you know I
was saying like taking him for an iron
aren't the same mmm that's all I'm
saying
those are not the same level comes in
not even go absolutely absolutely but
again those were annual pass either we
can't we can't throw rods of rise up
around was lit rise if I'd have wrapped
in a machine Raisa Brian had a lot of
content bro like what you really not
given rise our respect they deserve out
here like Raza fire was good but that's
arguably I had like physicians under it
had five missions in Iran ha you
disrespectful right now you see it's
very it had five missions oh my gosh at
we glad to glad to talk about this rise
of mine disrespect in here which was
cool in the rain the rain was cool but I
was like how much did it give you
outside of those two what else was there
and they add they had on what was the
thing they added the Omni amulets or
whatever would happen yeah no gameplay
mechanics I ban it was late they had a
separate gameplay space we shouldn't
have this we should have have this right
a rise of iron you give me all these
load rupees is still in comparing the
reservoir and I'm hoping I'm going to be
good I'm hoping we don't know listen I
hear what you're going bro we know me
you good this is a fun one you know at
the end of the day is you know it's just
two different trains I thought you know
and your train of thought is look you
know right now hold the fort down you
know resources are limited which they
are coming from you're not nothing
you're saying is incorrect like that
well I'm like oh my god I guess from me
my mindset is always like you know who's
to say that d3 if we wait that it
actually hits the home run and people
still around a witness that's why I'm
worried about the tea in the stadium
when you hit the home run and there's no
one everybody then checked out and they
like everything is before at least if we
had a couple of low bombs between you
know I'm saying I was just thinking that
hey people are stick around
people are say you know whatever so it
who's gonna
around that's the that's my question is
if you release something in September
and it's a rise of iron who's going to
play that are you going to bring casual
yes of course you will I will the
hardcore will but the casual is not
going to come back for the second
expansion on a game from two years ago
if it's done well and they have great
content yeah well the big can it beat
forsaken did yeah this is not gonna be
forsaken there's no way in hell this is
forsaken
we had a seat we got to see and I just
don't think they can put something
together with that so yeah well we've
never go GUI never go now apparently
never gonna agree on that we got we got
lots of podcasts and come back so anyway
I haven't even been reading chat by the
way so I know you guys haven't raised up
I know transom I've been trying to look
at it but it's like my greens all like I
got too much on my screen right now so
afraid the rumor about destiny 3 though
I do want to cover this whatever yeah
and this is why I say like destiny 3 is
gonna be your big focus mmm potentially
going to be bringing in your space
Doritos which is potentially going to be
the Vale which is potentially going to
be your basically this is gonna be the
darkness this is gonna be what brings d1
together and this is the people who are
equal to us light vs. dart they're the
other side of that they're supposed to
be just about as powerful so when you
get to that point of like these veil
creatures whatever they are like they're
to a point where they are in come into
our solar system because the travelers
here and the travelers who can resurrect
their God this is the potential lore
that's been leaked out there so you have
you know a pretty big story lots of
stuff coming full circle mm-hmm and it's
like this could be the time like you
have Mara who's potentially out doing
things you have Aldrin who's potentially
still we don't know you have all these
stuff like setting up and it's like and
I think that's why for me I would rather
see d3 take all of these stories they've
been building for friggin 6 years and
like actually
oh and may you didn't trash content feed
it in a one-week cinema nothing and drip
feed it with all we gonna go do groan
well six times again another no this is
trash we are not in a good place
I'm not going to let that ride man we
are not in a good place is a very
average place that we are settling for
because we're worried about their
resources I don't care if this game is
not in a good place it's over there is
no chance for the magical homeland come
back story you've got to keep trying
you've got to keep putting it out right
now is not that great I'm sorry it's not
man it's average I'm so concerned about
every other game and everything else
that's going on as opposed to I need to
be consistently playing destiny this
this structure is not working we gotta
call it what it is it's not sorry I just
think III has potential to be really
really cool and if they focus on that
then I think it's gonna be worth them to
spend the time to do this mmm-hmm facts
said Fred if you gotta go
see you I don't know if you're leaving
enough he just said it's been a very
emotional block yesterday keep the gonna
miss this guy I don't get a chance to
argue about destiny at least yours they
like to talk to someone who's just as
passionate about it and to have these
viewpoints this is really good this is
realize I haven't said once that I
absolutely love this content do know I'm
like you good with this no I never once
said that I've never once said that okay
have I I'm just like I know you feel a
difference though like just just taller
well it's like a lot for me
like taking King mmm forsaken amazing
content I love those moments I love last
wish the 24 hour minute and two second
rate sorry dado but you know all of
those pieces are awesome but we're at a
point to where Bungie is at a crossroads
they don't have Activision the money
isn't there they're trying to figure out
what's going on they have a lot of balls
up in the air they're trying to figure
out and for me
just like how long you gonna wait for a
rockstar game because they do it right
I want Bungie to do it right once they
haven't yet destiny one came out not in
that great of a space had some issues
had some like definitely issues or
rewriting stories the year before all
that craziness and then the whole I
can't remember the music guy you know
Mario Mario done yeah Marty like that
whole issue with him came out another
Jason's heretic oh cool
then we had destiny to come out they
tried to throw everything in there they
tried too casual eyes that they tried to
do all these things and do it I want
them to just be like okay I would rather
them literally drop every I would rather
them do nothing for the next year to me
you know this is me and this is where my
point of view is coming from I would
them drebber not put anything out and
say hey I know we're live service game
we're gonna leave this in a state we'll
have like some people like you know will
maybe do some sandbox updates here and
there and we're just diving 100% into
our next major and breathe the Musa who
saw it out donkey talk about you trying
to work through it you talk because at
some point late I mean you every major
large game CD Projekt RED with witcher 3
going to cyberpunk 2077 they're not life
servicing things things they are focused
they're doing their internal testing
they're building these things they're
working on scripts they're doing all
this stuff the more you pull away within
one studio now because they don't have
help anywhere else the more you pull
away from somewhere else it takes away
from the focus on what's next
let me so basically let me just clarify
what you're saying just got based on
what you can channel based on destiny to
if I say okay losing it there's a reason
for that because I would wait for d3
what's your say just so we clarify have
this one record is in theory what
division would you want them to go away
take the feedback you know what
everything they got to work on so that
you have that brand new founding right
and then like how Division two is
starting right now you know super strong
all the
issues that we have for the most part
you know most people have for the most
part are better dressed super you know
some strong launched boom out the gate I
understand it I understand it I think
the difference is I just think the
climate is different and I everything
you're saying is not wrong I just worry
about the climate that we're in this is
not back in the day this is not two
three years ago
there's battle royale now there's all
these looter shooters you know saying
boy lands this division is now in
position that's basically us
relinquishing the belt and say yeah and
obviously right now mm-hmm
the vision came so weakened and they
swung well mmm I haven't even touched
the game yet and I can probably agree to
that because they took the time to do
that but what are they do in the interim
hmm they like had live maintenance they
added little things here and there and
then when they came swinging my man
would say I love him how la this is what
I'm talk he says how does warframe have
big content updates every three months
and there were smaller dev Bungie I
can't give them excuse I'm trying to say
like I really it's nice that they're
struggling or whatever you feel about
David I really don't care get it
together you got these other teams just
doing it out of justice as unit we just
got done talking about their engine
being ultra slow if their engine is an
issue they have to start that process
over some point that process has to
start like somewhere they have to decide
to be like whether it was d1 that like
the engine bled into d2 at someone
they've got to be like they either have
to rehash the engine or something and
that's a that's an iteration that's not
an experiment you know they may need to
do it in it's just so difficult out here
in these resources streets how about you
go partner up how about you call Marcus
oh you call somebody and partner up if
it's so difficult that you can't do this
on your own because we're in dangerous
territory that's that that's all I'm
gonna say I think we're just in very
dangerous territory and I would I would
love for it to be able to just to kind
of go hibernation and you know you know
see if they can withstand that the storm
and I mean how much is division to admit
of the mine Sharon lost Division one
been in the mind share before Division
two
came out and passed like year but
division what was so trashed rusty what
are you got a destiny to do it thinks
not forsaken but yes okay
you talking sassy you think of destiny
two year one how did that come out poor
but you have to the holy fire by the
time Kurt somewheres got there go to
numbers no it was a commercial success
that's fine like you always what is
about for them right but how much of
that again you have Activision involved
you have them supporting paying big
bills things like that mmm-hmm so the
vision one comes out not great falling
away working on their stuff they did one
point eight which did bring a lot of
things back but again how much did one
point eight bring back for people
playing Division two I haven't tried for
like ten minutes but I didn't go back
division to mmm house Division two
coming out fantastic ok destiny to not
saying forsaken not other things you
can't live service these games forever
destiny to we've been through this move
on destiny to comes out as ok mmm yeah
and said for it division wants messed up
once that's need to messed up twice you
already burn people enough and get but
here's the thing though here's the
difference that's why you know we do
chant they burn people twice and people
still here in care that's the difference
the gunplay is like no other the
co-operative is like no other the raids
are like no other they are the best as
I'm trying to test I've never seen a
game do this in the history of gaming
I've never seen a game mess up so many
times and people be like you know what
that new contents out oh my god oh my
god back that's destiny that's what you
know they're the best eyesore trying to
say they can't do it anybody can do it
it's them they have proven time and time
again when their back is against the
wall at the lowest point they somehow
magically resurrect and I would relate
and I would rather them do that with d3
because I'd rather give them time to do
it I'm saying they already proved they
can do it so I'm not even I'm not
I'm not working they've proven to me
that when the back is against the wall
every time we came off Kosovo Cyrus bro
do you realize what that was
remember you remember the apology do you
remember what he was flashlight and we
did curse of Osiris but do you remember
people saying what are you doing a
destiny podcast for we've come from the
dot have some faith we've come from the
Dark Ages we survived we have a destiny
poet we have a Decimus a comet we have a
destiny podcast after forsaken and guess
what we're talking about the vision to
an anthem now just cuz it's part of the
picture right but this is dead there
self-impose we're gonna try something
new we're gonna be edgy we're gonna be
cute
this is them being cute Q ain't working
now let's get back to business
that's all I'm sure they've shown I'm
never gonna not I'm not gonna bet
against somebody who's proven to me that
they can do something they've always
done it that's all I'm saying like why
all of a sudden I'm act like they can't
do it now did a champ
it'll pass we love this game so much
you've shown that that gum play even
when you play division gum playing
destiny even when you play these other
games cooperative air destiny would eat
only thing you say baby PvP is don't
battle royal okay fine
but these other games have shown they
still went Destiny's on there is nothing
better that's just the facts let's not
let's not give up just yet that's the
difference you think I'm giving up I'm
more what I want is the way playing no
I'm literally not doing that I'm not
living the white flag I say you know
actually what I'm saying the difference
is I'm saying Bungie is so Bungie and
you just said it right there for me you
said when their back is against the wall
when they're at their lowest when they
come back with that haymaker call
destiny three cool it's called commie
three it's not that's not happening
rumor not rumors you yeah so so
I was like rumor or not know like they
they've this has been destiny to cycle
they're gonna finish that cycle up and
they're gonna go for the they're gonna
swing for the fences again but that's
you said when they do it best and I
think they're going to I just don't
think right now if they have to make
that decision on Reese of like
structures changing and things like that
servicing a live game if they make this
little life they put a bandaid on it for
a little while mm-hmm
they can they can do what they do best
and do something force they can do
something bigger than Forsaken which the
compactive and I'll see you back here in
September 2020 yep okay this day we all
other side offense it is a fun one it's
gonna be interesting see but the rumors
are leading towards your point so
regards to how I feel at the end of the
day the rumors suggest and this is a
credible source right we will agree that
this source is very credible fairly yeah
yeah and you know the rumors suggested
is is gonna be another arm type of suit
your annual pass type of situation
all I could note for even though it's in
your favor right now is that I get
another Raza fine situation because if
you remember Raza vile wasn't supposed
to exist
nope that was that was supposed to be d2
you know say that so if the light is
what I'm hoping for and that's what you
owe for so we'll see what ends up
happening
I mean who they get those engagement
numbers I mean we got it well no black
armor we got a raid a season of opulence
we got a raid that's two raids outside
of that in an annual pass even if we get
two raids over the course of a year and
they have you know now they have four
seasons to spread some stuff out it's
just one of those I think I'm not saying
it's gonna be a great time I'm honestly
not and I all agree I honestly don't
think that it's gonna be that the
greatest time for destiny too but if
they like if they continue to learn
that's the key this is the big key in
caveat
division learned from their mistakes in
destiny to can learn from this next year
iron things figure things out fold it
all in this Knight package when they
present d3 I think in 2020 it's gonna be
presented well
well according to the rumors it looks
like they're going your way hopefully
we'll be around and exist in existence
yeah and these podcasts are gonna have a
few other games involved why the last
word we change flexibility but again we
change the name to have flexibility just
because we can't always talk about
destiny it can't always that's the thing
it's like it cannot forever be thee the
peak every single time it's tough so
especially as they're on their own
anyway moving alone I don't even know
how to wrap up after that one this is
already two hours and for long point
it's long point flash flashes definitely
not a flash in the pan
case you guys have been living under a
rock
shout out to Jason Shire and his Kotaku
well they put a hell of a lot of work
into this article 11,000 words of what
went into anthems development six years
like lack of vision certain things
different ways you had the Frostbite
engine with us ups and downs yet
engineers being pulled in different
places and you had different studios
that had different visions so much
happened in the if you guys have not
read this article I'm gonna take this
right here I'm gonna put it in chat it's
right there if you haven't read it truly
this is one of those it is long this
will take you a while it is chapters of
a book it is not short read it to get an
idea what thing what these people go
through and this is one of those points
where I'm gonna empathize and say you
can't kill devs because of reading this
article interesting and that's one of
those pieces that I want to go back to
and just literally be like wind bite
when Bioware's multiple studios in EA
and all this was in development you have
honestly you had people taking stress
leave
yeah and that's that's rough you have
people getting crunched so hard that
they're like quitting the job because of
stress they're going we've heard about
it people are thinking about like
unionizing gaming's and stuff like that
like so
I'm just getting to a level where it's
not sustainable to maintain like sanity
like that and what they're asking people
but you also have a point where before
e3 and 2017 anthem was called something
different
mm-hmm it was called beyond like beyond
the wall and you're not are you serious
right now like yeah that's what it was
so I mean this like I don't want to go
fully into it I just kind of want to get
your general overview thoughts on just
what it looks like it went through and
then you know just like what do you what
do you feel like I don't know what do
you think this does like industries what
industry wise for Bioware like this is
one of your beloved studios like even
giving you like Dragon Age Inquisition
and pieces like that just showing like
it was like hell in a handbasket and
then it cams together at like the 11th
hour like just what are your thoughts
about what you get from this whole thing
cuz it's it's it's a big one well a lot
of first thing a lot of this stuff I buy
from all right because I initially I
were trying to make sense of how it got
into the state did a guy I knew they
were having issues you know I'm saying
there's no doubt we knew it needed to
bake I always knew that part but um you
know I'm conflicted here I gotta be
honest II there's some issues there's
some things that really rubbed me wrong
in a sense of you know kind of like the
more we have the discussion with
Activision and Munsch right and there
were a lot of things you like activision
had to be the cause at and Mister and
I'm not saying EA is to be absolved here
they're not you know the Frostbite
engine right now was a big problem and
you know but at the same time you know
even though it was the matter of fact it
was the initiative by EA that they
wanted to do their own homegrown engine
and move everything over there
eventually and I believe five four
started it and then the Bioware guy said
okay you know what let's move you know
proactive and let's just get used to it
now and with our development and the
thing about it is that you know it's
just after seeing all these problems and
seeing all these things going on people
just struggling with this engine and and
just the indecisiveness and people
leaving and Casey Hudson come back and
all this stuff I mean it just really
goes to show me like this thing was
really
in development hell and um - here's the
thing when you get to a point where
you're at year three and year four and
no one knows what the game is
if Pro I mean again I'm trying to be as
respectful as possible I'm not a
developer but I understand the
constraints I understand difficult it is
but I also have to say like can I really
get mad at EA EA says you got to get it
out okay fine
all right they delay it that's like six
seven years cycle though oh I don't know
I mean it's it is both sides of this for
sure yeah that's a long time to tell a
publisher you know we don't know what we
got it just feel like it was so
ambitious and they just couldn't sell it
and I'm hearing indecisive just a small
thing just to decide on a small thing
they would leave meetings and no one
would have any you know what they're
really gonna do again it just screams
dysfunction we know there was different
teams at one point Canadian team and
this team you know and again I'm not
gonna say EA DAA definitely was pressure
and I feel the forest bright engine was
the profit that way with Mass Effect
when the ads are stupid facial
animations I'm like why don't they just
use the internet they had before which
is unreal so it's just it's a sad tale
it's a sad tears a cautionary tale about
overworking it's about mismanagement and
poor leadership and um you feel for them
because that's destiny fans you know we
kind of can relate d-1 you know I think
yeah how things were and um you know
just trying to get the thing out the
door and in their credit let's be honest
yes is it you know a lot of issues no
doubt but we have to admit from a core
feel standpoint right what they are
enduring out my brother's point this is
great right yeah cuz it with all it is
crime scene II I'm like how did we even
get what we got because I was like this
was based on what I read this thing was
supposed to be to stick figures running
out there like what we have now
basically nine months is what we have
and that's very impressive to have what
we have the feel of the game like that
will honestly say like it
have the deaf that doesn't have the
story doesn't have the features it is a
shell of a framework but the feel like
this game is like if this is something
they can build like this is water I'm
like this is one where they kind of have
to just do a Division one or they'd be
like yeah you think the lost and you're
like okay we're gonna give you I don't
even think they should do Cataclysm
honestly because at this point it's it's
honestly a lost cause because well
you're gonna bring back this is a
pointer you're like okay we're gonna
relaunch it we're gonna give it at a
discount we'll have some different
microtransactions in there but they need
to take like take that next year that
this thing needed to pay can go we got
to now make a game mm-hmm yeah I mean
shut the well black jockeys make some
great comments yeah I struggle with that
nine months of development here's the
dead it's like you like you said you
know kudos to them in the respect that
they got what they got out considering
now that the curtains been unveiled
because it's just like I said you gotta
take the L like you said pack it up
you know focus everything on getting it
right towards the end of second even
though people probably not gonna be
there but did you go hard with an anthem
to and then you know because again the
core gameplay is there so um yeah I mean
this this was great investigative
reporting you know I love learning about
all the things they were going through
it'll be interesting to see if they
could turn around and be interest to see
if EA cuz the problem the problem is I
think the reason why people champion so
hard for this game E is that one its
Bioware right mmm the history but the
main thing is people Cham because they
know EA's history and EA has a notorious
history if you don't knock it out the
park they get rid of you and this is by
wit and I think that's why people were
so defensive not you I'm just saying in
general night I know people first hands
like shots my boy carbides who gotta put
you out there I hear you I don't want to
see Bioware go away you know I'm saying
I don't wanna and I get it that's
childhood I guess that's that's my
that's my company you know I'm saying
and one could hope because I saw that
they update updated the statement and
case got it actually responded to this
article and finally admission cuz the
first response was that week that was
can was because like you guys are toned
down but the second one was like nope
you guys are right
they've got soul-searching you do you
know saying and all you can hope for
them
at this point is you know I don't know
if they'll have a taken king or any of
them but it may be a Division one kind
of thing where you just you know strip
feed do your strategy I think that's
what your strategy yeah Jimmy let it go
into the bushes then you come back
strong hopefully with the advent it's
not what you unless you see so much like
the name of the game changing it before
an e3 conference because they're like
old beyonds gonna be too hard to get the
trademark for him like so then like you
have a story that's changed multiple
times over people don't know what
they're making the flying was in and out
and in and out like the flying was
changed three times or so I'm like are
you serious like we almost didn't know
how how good they nailed out how good
they nailed the fly cousin into history
right right easy and that yeah I think
that's the biggest thing it's like shout
out to the people who are now working on
this because for one their job is like
mmm eat he'll like not gonna be an easy
thing to do but the work they've put in
since they finally had that vision like
that line to go forward on they have
done a lot now I was like yeah is like
was there that much to work with do we
have that many enemy varieties there's
just the big like Titans there's a
reason for that and this is one of those
were you just at this point I have
compassion because yeah we watched
destiny do similar things they like had
to rebuild a game 16 months before
destiny one came out so the story it was
completely disjointed same thing here
you've had a story go through four
different iterations you have developers
that have like stress leave and some
don't come back and it's just all this
other stuff so it's like it's just a
brutal thing to read for what people
like trying to go through and it's just
got to be horrible to be like hey I just
built it built this really awesome art
asset we're gonna just go ahead and
format your hard drive because that
doesn't mean anything anymore like it's
just it's just bad like the more island
there the people who are still there
like shout out to him because they they
have they want this game to work well
it's like I've seen the Ben Irving the
people on social like the ones that
they've tried to really stick with it
and it's impressive so it's it's a sad
state to see and it falls on both sides
of it it's like you have the
my brother was talking about it as well
and he was just saying it's like you
have the Frostbite engineers the ones
who help understand and explain the
engine and build the piece in the
usually they need getting pulled to FIFA
then you have that point where you're
like CA that's a but there you have
Bioware like I don't know what the hell
we're making for four years and but this
is the point where it's like EA had had
to make a call be like and this is where
their physical pieces like they made a
hundred million dollars sure
line how they got that I don't even know
but that's fine but the big thing is
it's like they knew the game was trash
right I do yes I mean basically told
them it was trash to see oh oh whatever
yeah but do you as EA be like hey we've
had so far four years of sunk costs
maybe five basically and it's like
what's the better prospect here it's
like do you if you delay it again is it
but if you delay it it may actually come
out well it's like they have a point
where they have they have stockholders
to be like hey we didn't hit that but
and this is one thing somebody said it
earlier in chat gaming has become all
about the money
and it's like an EA saying and that's
but that's the other thing too it's like
we I want to know when the decision of
apex was in there to be like oh I can
tell you what that was I've talked about
oh my ILP but it's like oh crap this
isn't gonna be right is that what you're
basically saying oh yeah basically they
knew I'm little I'm so confident on my
theory now they knew the state anthem
was in right and they they would
consider was a Apex was hedging their
bed they were like you know what this
may flop now crazy things and them still
did well at MVP we just got a money but
we'll get to that but apex was like you
know what we got this project right here
cuz it's stealth launched and the timing
to me was way weird it was literally
like a day or the week before their
fiscal calendar year ended so this way
they can count that apex numbers on the
book for that year and the year would
end up looking like a success because
prior to that them EA franchises was
definitely in a butcher's they were not
doing well and they were hope and anthem
was gonna be the saving a like wait the
way these things look at so yeah I'm a
firm of firm belief that apex Legends
launched
as that Mulligan because we all say like
you really didn't make any sense to
launch it so close to anthem just like a
timing what's weird yeah you just can't
it well it's like titanfall in
battlefield 5 all over again titanfall 2
yo thanks an awesome game by the way
titanfall 2 is a fun as hell game the
six-hour story was really cool like
nicely well put together
smash between too many things why does
EA like literally throwing both of their
greed gaming I don't care about they
don't care about this that's not even a
strategic decision at that point to say
I mean Anthony it is for them look okay
Anthony apex is a strategic strategic
hedge that's the thing like you it's
feels back to my word of tone-deaf it
feels like completely to have blinders
on to take titanfall to a shooter and
battlefield 5 a shooter within a within
a month or less it was like weaker I
feel like those those make even less
sense than apex and anthem those are at
least hedge of battle royale
single-player there's some sense in
there but granted you have to feel like
a free game Oh like you're gonna strip
player base from a little bit everything
but you're also stripping him from your
own and that's kind of a hard part but
like the battlefield and titanfall thing
that was that's not always good but
that's not even their fiscal part that's
why I knew still never understood that
technically was it technically was
because they do want they could have
easily delayed titanfall 2 or mu Liam
battlefield is gonna stay but Titans who
could have moved until I next year of
whatever Marshall whatever that would
have been outside of that fiscal space
so their thing is okay this is how they
looking from pure greed we will take a
short term hit on I mean what they'll
they'll take they'll go for the whole
get everything in this fiscal joint and
get all this short term money in the
long term
titanfall dies out but look 2017 was
good we can say the investors look 2017
it's great I know it for as a gamer it
sucks and it's it kills the franchise
because now you do that but now guess
what who's clamoring for tanks for three
like that you know it sucks it's just
pure greed driven it is sad that's how
they look at things they don't care
about lopsided
packing releases on top of each other
they don't care about the long-term if
they just want to sit there and have
this participate Rover yeah look at our
numbers for this year the count for
school year look what we did
and then you're looking at the
franchise's like year but the healthy
franchises so you know so it sucks it's
it literally sucks and I agree with you
I thought it was tone-deaf and was
tone-deaf then and now with this
situation one could just hold that
they're able to turn this thing around
man we're not just okay alone to support
it because I mean they're this that's
just kind of thing so they gotten this
far they've got a place to relate now
this is like they have if they have a
framework of a game sadly it's kind of
where it's at you have like abilities
you have graphics you have like the
world which is only one so it's like now
is your time now build your game and
that's the point where they just need to
go off kind of stop the support of the
live things and say hey this is the
Cataclysm piece and like these other
acts that we had right now we just want
to make we don't we want to we want to
do a full release we want to give you
guys a big reason to come back so I mean
at that point that be a game to were
like yeah anthem one you might do a free
to play later a ten dollar version or
something like that later on yeah cuz
they literally apex literally anthem and
their own battle for our game in
battlefield five deal whatever battle
royale in one shot just by what because
they was so concerned about the fiscal
year but again short-term game versus
long-term game and as they just continue
to look for the money short-term share
not the chat by the way you guys have
been awesome I haven't been saying as
much as yet said Fred had just and it's
gaming has like the evolution of gaming
has changed you've got higher developer
graphics that takes longer time to make
there's more resources involved now you
gotta focus on graphics and story and
gameplay and online multiplayer ability
and like the feelings and your timing of
marketing it's like everything is so fat
like games release all year long now
that's kind of the thing about the
evolution of III not even having as much
of a weight to it because games release
all year long so there's so much in the
world of gaming now it's like it's hard
to it's it is hard to it is rough to
make a game like a game developers like
people like I'd love to make like work
with games and things like it's it's
brutal it honestly is and when they talk
about like
unions and things yeah you better be
passionate about it because you're gonna
be probably working more than you're
getting paid no absolutely absolutely
man you got people like need them in but
do I didn't you cut out sorry you cut
out in the worst moment what do you say
as it did you get people like me
demanding cut yeah I figure out make fun
of myself but that's like that's kind of
the this is good to see this is one of
those things like gamers not the
twelve-year-old plant fortnight on his
phone who doesn't give a damn or care or
have any relevance of like I've been in
a working world I know what like the
overtime the brutal hours can be like
into a point on it most more extreme
level on something you want to love but
you it's you can't like the people who
still like are developing for this game
like I don't know how they can still
love after what they've been through
that's tough it's just the hardest thing
of in so but the good the good thing
though is an article like this helps put
light on a negative situation to induce
change yes you want to get raped over
there you want them to get ripped over
the coals because at the end of the day
that's what that's they had to go
through they got killed triad the same
in a lot of this stuff he does make
nobody say I know he gets a bad rap a
lot of sudden it's not everything I
agree with him but he's a passionate
gamer he's a passionate destiny plays a
passionate Lula shooter kind of thing
so his whole thing's I gotta get to the
source of it why did this happen what's
going on kind of deal and when it gets
to light now the company kind of gets
exposed for these practices right yeah
what has changed and hopefully and then
I saw a Casey Hudson recent statement
they taking it to heart you know
hopefully this can now start to
turnaround process absolutely so yeah if
you guys haven't read that one
definitely go check it out it's not hard
Kotaku and them you'll find it it's easy
mm-hm but it's definitely one that's
really really cool and worth the read
yes sir and then final piece I know far
behind in the world of division I'll fly
to it but we got like tier five is
coming and the raid I don't know a date
they don't think there's a date yet but
they're they're teasing it's not that
far yeah not that far they're definitely
teasing tidal basin comes up you know
you got the stronghold jumping out tents
difficulty worlds here fire progression
a lot finally you know it's gonna be a
lot of these actually some exotics that
gets released um they have weekly
invasions they have some apparel event
that's happening May 2nd so they're
giving up what I like that they did is
that they held it back with a bunch of
fixes before they could release and
actually they got some cool new fixes
for skills right now shout out to the
people use this to a sniper turret they
actually made a nerf to one of the more
popular rifles a little over pyro power
the MK 17 and the sniper and 7000 so I
mean 700 so um look right now I like the
pacing I like the fact that they're
saying you know what we don't got a rush
this stuff out just yet let's get it
right let's make sure base gameplay is
right and fixes are being done in a
timely fashion before they can um get
this thing going so I'm very curious to
see how the stronghold is I gotta get
myself up to level I've been behind I'm
not played in a while Sam and traveling
to all much craziness but um yeah I mean
it sounds pretty exciting I'm dying to
see how this armed stronghold is and
then we get to see the raid and then I
gotta say it now because that's a little
spoiler you've been away um did you hear
any details on the Ray because I did oh
I've seen in a trailer
no yeah now let me know let me know on
second row which will keep me going but
like I know division I got one copy it's
there I just haven't heard a boiler
warning in five yes in four in three in
two and action
lesson alright for my understanding it
is literally what I could have hoped for
and it basically from my understanding
there's a bridge portion the teams get
split you see the teams of four and one
team is working on like um almost like a
I'm sing like stealth and espionage and
the other team is full-on frontal
assault and then from my understanding
it's just gaining towards this bridge
and enters this actual I guess the
airport or whatever it is now they still
just I didn't read everything because I
like to I want to spoil everything but
from all accounts I'm hearing mechanics
I'm hearing splitting up and I'm hearing
different gameplay styles and that
fights me so again still haven't played
it still gotta see it in action but the
initial reports the initial leaks of
this operation dark hours gives me hope
that yo they're actually onto something
and and I got a shout them out as far as
mission design because even as I've been
playing just the standard current
missions yeah man they've been intense
man they've been well done it literally
you've got to work together it's a fight
free life and on it's not just I didn't
I never got the sense like it was you
know just room to room to room kind of
deal it's it's literally different
things going on and you've got to focus
on key people ability and skills
otherwise it can make like difficult man
so um you know we'll see what happens
you know again it's early you know these
are just initial leaks we shall see but
all intensive part of the early stuff
I'm hearing about operation though I was
very promising nice well I'm gonna be
behind in that world for a while but at
some point I do want to jump in I've
heard like a lot of good things like
whether you may or may not like the
story like as you think you nailed the
one that I've heard probably one of the
most omission designs like each one
feels so like and they're different
yeah just feel so cool like the control
points the feeling of like people coming
from multiple directions yeah it it's
honestly what just I knew Sakura was
like timing wise I couldn't do both so I
was like be my ninja first like
division's who's waiting for me so I'm
definitely looking forward to it
absolutely man okay that's what I get
man yeah that'll pretty much wrap it up
hopefully you guys watching live enjoy
the faces if you're watching this one on
YouTube thank you guys for all tuning in
this is on audio as well so if you guys
are looking for the audio version and
I'm gonna slap this all voice over again
in the beginning this is on audio so if
you guys are looking for that remember
it's on most things except pod bean
right now I think is the only one that
hasn't made it out - but it's on iTunes
Google Spotify and that's where most of
them aren't going to be watched anyway
so this will be out there I'll try and
get up today actually for the audio and
yeah I know we we got heated it's a it's
an argument it's a difference of
opinions out of
yes for a games that we love like it's
weird you know five years in and we both
want amazing things out of this game we
just have different opinions on win and
where it's coming from but honestly it's
a point of I'm not gonna stop playing
destiny of course not of course like
it's it's always gonna be there but I
think at this point it's also a time
where as there are other games like
division it's like there are other
things to experience and just don't miss
them all because sometimes some of them
are really good like suck your own
division - both like they're worth your
time and and just and the biggest thing
I'll say yeah just just have fun and
enjoy enjoy your time that you've enjoy
your time with whatever it is you want
to do if you're not enjoying it then
find something that you find fun that's
the big deal I don't wanna go too deep
on anything I know you probably know
where I'm thinking about going I just
want to say like yeah just enjoy your
time in your moments that you've got cuz
you never know and honestly it's just
like make the most of what you got
absolutely my yosh out out - to chat
absolutely fantastic we try to get the
technical difficulties nailed down you
know eventually it was just a weird day
nothing was going right when hang out so
we really respect you guys - still
camera still rocking on us this long
week long time and I'll get shot to the
chat you know we get when a beauty boxes
or other side let us know what you guys
think about the format to like us on
screen with the campfire like this is
different we're kind of doing it through
discord not hang out and it's a
different format stream in one place I
mean if this is something you guys are
fans of or not let us know because I
don't know how actually to get our faces
on screen so we'll look around and see
but we're trying to trying to mix it up
and actually let you guys see our are
heated arm-waving crazy discussions so
charlie bond just he's gotta get my
India because I'll be wearing shirts for
y'all to see and he's messing that part
up so once we get there part since
that's it
I need to crop your shirt in here just
need to make it longer
yeah yes man is cool stuff Daisy stand
up keep saying not a seated Gaming man
you say with your chest about 45 minutes
so ya comin soon another invitation of
the nine we'll see if we get a cinematic
this week or we continue to wait but for
all you guys out there it's been awesome
this morning thank you guys we'll see
you soon
have a good one and yeah adios and that
is oh let's see what we're trying to do
a wrap up here we want to do this right
so well I'll say and that is and we'll
say the last word together cool alright
so and that is the last word